ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
POWER QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CERVANTES.
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
RICK'S [inaudible]
WORD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
AS PART OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
OBSERVANCE OF LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROSS.
THANK YOU WE OFFER IN A PRAYER
OF BLESSING SONGS THE SERRANO
BIGHORN SHEEP SONG.
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY -- TO THE
SONG TALKS ABOUT SEARCHING FOR
THE BIG HORN SHEEP FROM THE
SERRANO PEOPLE THE OBVIOUS CAM
CLAN.
OF THE NIGHT OF OCT -- THEY'RE
NOT [inaudible]
FINAL BOMB THE NIGHT OF OCT.
MOM BUT THEY'RE NOT A BOMB AND
YEAH [inaudible]
LONG.
I HAVE LONG.
BOMPTON ARMS LONG -- THE NIGHT
OF OCT.
BOMB AT THE NIGHT OF ALL.
BOMB AND I BOUGHT.
MOM AND I BOUGHT -- THEN
[inaudible]
BOMPTON OURS LAW [inaudible]
THE BOMB [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THREE OF US AS SHE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER REEVES.
OKAY READY BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO WINS
ABLE TENSE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE SUMMIT AT SEVEN AM ME OUT OF
THE WAY OF THE ROSE IN THE
NUMBER SEVEN CURTIS PRESIDING TO
THIRTY DAWSON WAS 11-3 MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY.
ALL THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP
CHEN. FOR FUNERAL DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY
SALAS.
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE WHEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ALLOW SOMETHING
MEMBERS GONZALEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SMITH AND WEBER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OUT RIGGERS GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT HIS DESK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ GUESTS WILL BE
IN THE AREA MEMBERS DESK FOR THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOMETHING MEMBERS BIGELOW BLOOM
DOLLY KALRA AND WEBER TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IS PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ITEM ONE FIFTY AB SET -- ONE
NINETY SEVEN SKEWS ME ONE
SEVENTY NINE RAY S. ITEM ONE
FIFTY TWO AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
CRISTINA GARCIA I DON'T WANT
SIXTY NINE A. B.. NINE FORTY
THREE TWO DAVID CHIU.
THE CLERK WILL NOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BILLS
AND APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILLS THE SECOND
REFILE.
BILLS ARE NO LONGER FISCAL AB
SIX HUNDRED KANSEN CHU AB ELEVEN
THIRTY A GALLAGHER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER IN PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY ONE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER A. B. SEVEN NINETY SIX
HOLDEN.
FROM THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US WHO JOINED US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE DOCTOR
WEBER.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU HAVE GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY WITH US.
TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY THIS CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. TO INTRODUCE TO
YOU A POWERFUL SISTERHOOD CALL
THE ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY.
THE ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN OH EIGHT
ON THE CAMPUS OF HOWARD
UNIVERSITY.
OVER A HUNDRED MEMBERS IN THE
CAPITAL TODAY FOR THEIR ANNUAL
DAY OF ADVOCACY.
OKAY DAY AT THE CAPITOL IS AN
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAM OF ALPHA
KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
INCORPORATED.
DESIGNED TO BETTER QUITE THE
MEMBERS WITH HOW GOVERNMENT AND
THE POLITICAL PROCESS WORKS. TWO
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINETEEN MARKS THE TWENTY YEAR
OF ADVOCACY FOR THESE LADIES.
THEY HAVE A FULL DAY OF MEETINGS
AND ACTIVITIES PLANNED TO MARK
THIS MOMENT TO A MOMENTOUS
OCCASION.
TODAY I HAVE ON THE FLOOR WITH
ME MISS PATRICIA MARSHALL
MACKENZIE WHO IS THE LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON.
LESLIE TEN SON WHO IS A
CALIFORNIA STATE COORDINATOR.
MISS CAROL OUR DICKS IN THE FAR
WEST REGIONAL COORDINATORS.
MR TO FAR MONEY ROLL THE FAR
WEST REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
INTERNATIONAL CONNECTIONS MISS
RENEE TERRY JONES WAS A PROTOCOL
OFFICER.
MEMBERS THERE ARE THERE HERE IN
THE GALLERY THERE'S SOME ON THE
FLOOR REPRESENTING THE ONE OF
THE ALL THE WEAPONS AND THE
OLDEST AFRICAN AMERICAN SORORITY.
IN THE IN THE IN IN THE U. S. OF
IN THE WORLD.
I WANTED SIMPLY ADD A COUPLE
THINGS TO IT BECAUSE SOMETIMES
WE THINK OF SORORITIES ND
FRATERNITIES AND MOST OF YOU
BEEN TO UNIVERSITIES KNOW ABOUT
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT START
ON CAMPUSES.
THE UNIQUE THING ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICANS SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES IS NOT JUST THEIR
HISTORY AND HOW THEY WERE FOUND.
MOST OF THEM CAME INTO EXISTENCE
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
JOIN WHITE SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES ON THE OTHER
CAMPUSES.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT UNLIKE OTHER SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES.
THE BLACK SORORITIES AND
NOT ONLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
THE UNDERGRADUATE.
BUT THEY'VE BECOME MORE POWERFUL
AS GRADUATES.
AND WHEN YOU BEGAN TO LOOK AT
THE A. K. A. AND ALL OF THE
OTHER EIGHT SORORITIES AND
FRATERNITIES.
IT'S THEIR LEGACY AFTER THEY
LEAVE THE CAMPUS THAT IS A
POWERFUL PIECE.
THESE ARE WOMEN WHO CONTINUE TO
SERVE AND TO GIVE WILL GIVE
LARGE NUMBERS OF SCHOLARSHIPS
AND RUN PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES UNLIKE OTHER
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES THE
KIND OF IN THEIR INFLUENCE AFTER
THEY LEAVE COLLEGE.
THEY MAY RELATE TO THEIR THIS
RORTY SINCE THE TURN OF THESE --
IN IN SOME KIND OF SOCIAL WAY
AND MAYBE TO ON THE CAMPUS WITH
THESE ARE POWER HOUSES IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES.
AND IS UPON THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THE A. K. A. IS A DELTA IS THE
CAP WAS THE ALFA FEEL MAGUS AND
THAT SAKE MODES IN ALL THE
OTHERS THE ZETAS AND ALL THE
OTHERS THAT EXIST.
THEY ARE THE POWER FORCES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THEIR COMMITMENT IS
UNQUESTIONABLE.
AND AS YOU LOOK AT THE SISTERS
IN THEIR RED.
OR PINK AND GREEN.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MY DAUGHTER
WEARS GRANT.
SEASON DON'T DON'T.
YOU KNOW SHE'S A DOCTOR.
BUT THE GOOD THING IS THAT WITH
THE RIVALRY AMONG THE IN THE
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES IT'S
MORE FUN THAN ANYTHING.
BECAUSE THERE'S THEIR COMMITMENT
TO OUR COMMUNITY IS UNIFIED.
AND I CELEBRATE THEM TODAY HERE
ON THE FLOOR AND AT THE CAPITOL
BECAUSE THERE YOU TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A MAKE A DIFFERENCE AROUND
THE WORLD AND AS I SAID OUR
SORORITIES A PATERNITY BECOME
MORE POWERFUL EVERY YEAR THAT
THEY LET THAT THEIR MEMBERS OF
THE ORGANIZATION.
AND THEIR POWER IS STRONGER IN
THE ALUMNI CHAPTERS THAT EVER
COULD BE AT THE UNDERGRADUATE
LEVEL ONCE AGAIN WELCOME TO THE
CAPITAL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I COULD PLEASE HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE GONNA BE MOVING TO THE
SPECIAL CEREMONY IN HONOR OF
SINGLE TAMAYO AND FOR THE LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND BE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY SEVEN AND THREE OF US IF
YOU'RE PREPARED TO READ.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS RELATIVE
TO SEE GO TOMORROW WE MYSTERY OF
US.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
I AM HONORED.
TO PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION.
TWENTY THREE WHICH MEMORIALIZES
SIEGEL THE MILE AS A SIGNIFICANT
DATE IN CALIFORNIA AND MEXICAN
HISTORY.
WE RECOGNIZE SINGLE THE MILE
BECAUSE IT SERVES AS A SYMBOL OF
OUR MEXICAN CULTURE.
OUR RESILIENCE AND OUR CHARACTER.
SIEGEL THE MILES A DAY WHEN WE
REFLECT ON THE COURAGE AND
ACHIEVEMENTS.
NOT ONLY FOR THE MEXICAN FORCES
AT PUEBLA.
BUT ALSO ON THE COURAGE.
AND THE INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS
AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF LATINOS
LIVING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
LET THE ALSO MAKE UP NEARLY 40%.
OF THE TOTAL POPULATION IN OUR
STATE.
IN OUR LATINO.
COMMUNITY HAS CHALLENGE THE
FRONTIERS OF SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
MILLIONS OF LATINOS HAVE
IMMIGRATED HERE IN SEARCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM.
MY OWN FAMILY MY GRANDPARENTS MY
MOTHER.
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA FROM MEXICO.
THEY DID SO BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
SEARCH OF A BETTER LIFE.
AND A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
MY FAMILY LIKE MILLIONS OF
OTHERS CAME HERE.
WILLING TO PLAY BY THE RULES.
WILLING TO WORK HARD.
WILLING TO GIVE BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
LUCKILY THE DOOR TO OPPORTUNITY
WAS STILL OPEN FOR MY FAMILY AND
MANY OTHERS.
YES IT WAS DIFFICULT.
YES TEN MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY.
NINE LIVED IN OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS.
WE LIVED IN THE SAME
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS WERE MY
GRANDFATHER WORKED.
BUT IT WAS THAT ROOF OVER OUR
HEADS.
THE RELENTLESS HARD WORK.
AND DRIVE MY GRANDFATHER. TO
PROVIDE A BETTER FUTURE FOR HIS
FAMILY FOR HIS CHILDREN.
THAT ALLOWED US TO GET OUT OF
THE FIELDS.
AND IN THE CLASSROOM.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
DID NOT LEAVE US BEHIND.
WE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY IN
THIS ROOM IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE DOOR TO
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
REMAINS OPEN. FOR ALL.
SEE GO THE MILE RECOGNIZES OUR
HISTORY.
AN IMPORTANT ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
PAST BUT ALSO REMINDS US OF
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE HAVE HERE
IN THIS CAPITAL.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO MAKE REAL
AND MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS IN
OUR CHILDREN.
AND IT SURE THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION IS AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
WE MUST UNDERSTAND THE STORY
PLIGHT OF OUR FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
WHO ENSURE THAT WE ALL HAVE FOOD
ON OUR TABLES?
WE MUST FIND A WAY TO PROVIDE
OUR FARMWORKERS WITH DIGNIFIED
AND QUALITY HOUSING THAT THEY
DESERVE.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
NOT JUST WEALTHY ZIP CODES HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE.
LET US KEEP THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ALIVE.
IN THE SPIRIT OF SINGLE MILE LET
US COME TOGETHER. TO RECOGNIZE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS STRONGER
BECAUSE OF OUR DIVERSITY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MYSTERY OF US AS
ANYBODY WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING.
AND HEARING ON THE SERVICE YOU
MAY CLOSE.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER SPEAKER I'M HONORED AGAIN
TO CELEBRATE OUR RICH HERITAGE
AND CULTURE.
WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK TO
IMPROVE THE OVERALL QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
A TWO SURE THAT MORE LIKE THE US
COULD ACHIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND IF YOU'D PLEASE OPEN
THE FIRST ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MYSTERY OF US THE
FIRST WHAT ROLL CALL WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS A COUPLE OF
IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS.
ON THE MEASURE WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO
THE LATINO CAUCUS CREATED LATINA
SPIRIT AWARDS TO RECOGNIZE
INDIVIDUALS WHO EXEMPLIFY THE
TRUE SPIRIT.
OUR LATINO CULTURE.
AND OF OUR LATINO CULTURE AND
HERITAGE.
TODAY WE HONOR NINE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REPRESENT A WIDE RANGE OF
TALENTS FOUND IN OUR STATE.
I AM A POINTY APPOINTING AN
ESCORT ESCORT COMMITTEE TO BRING
OUR SPECIAL GUEST ON TO THE
FLOOR FOR A SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS SHOULD RETIRE TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL
YOUR NAME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
RAMOS RODRIGUEZ CERVANTES
CRISTINA GARCIA.
ROBERT RIVAS EGGMAN GLORIA
MEDINA.
RAY IS BLANCA RUBIO.
EDUARDO GARCIA SANTIAGO LEE MON
THREE OF US.
CARILLO AND QUIRK SILVA.
OUR SPECIAL GUEST SENATORS.
HUESO ARCHULETA SUSAN REMOTE
RUBIO.
CAMBIADO AND HER TOTAL.
I ALSO ASK THAT SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN
LEADER MORE WE MARIE WALDRON
LATINO CAUCUS CHAIR LORETTA
GONZALEZ AND VICE CHAIR SENATOR.
MARIA ELENA DURAZO TO MOVE TO
THE CENTER AISLE TO RECEIVE OUR
HONOREES
.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
INTRODUCTIONS OF LATINO SPIRIT
AWARD HONOREES FOR TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE FIRST ON A RIVAS IN MEMORIA
THE LATINO CAUCUS RECOGNIZES
DELAYED CENTER RIGHT HAND
ALTHOUGH FRANCISCO DAY BY A FOR
HIS ROLE AS THE FOUNDER OF UCLA.
REPRESENTING UCLA IS DAVID HAYES
BUT T. STUFF DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF LATINO
HEALTH AND CULTURE.
HE IS ESCORTED BY SO MANY
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY RAMOS AND
CENTER HUESO.
THE HONORABLE RATE ALTHOUGH
FRANCISCO DE BY A IS UCLA'S
FORGOTTEN FOR FATHER.
HE WAS A COMMUNITY LEADER IS
HOME OF LOS ANGELES AND WAS
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE AT AGE.
TWENTY FIVE WELL IN THE SENATE
HE SECURED FUNDING FOR LOS
ANGELES THE STATE NORMAL SCHOOL.
THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WERE DIRECTED TO
ESTABLISH A BRANCH OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AT THE LOCATION OF THE LOS
ANGELES STATE NORMAL SCHOOL.
WITHOUT THE NORMAL SCHOOL THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN NO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
THE CAMPUS NOW KNOWN AS UCLA
WHICH MARKED AS ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN CENTER
RIGHT HAND ALTHOUGH FRANCISCO DE
BY A WAS ELECTED SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AT AGE.
TWENTY SEVEN AND SERVE IN THIS
CAPACITY FROM.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WELCOME OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN HONORE FOR IN
MEMORIAM THE LATE SENATOR RATE
ALTHOUGH FRANCISCO DE FRIDAY
.
WE ARE RE FOR CHEAP IN A
BUSINESS OR FOR LAMPREY IS TO
READ SEE DOMINGO'S SHE IS
ESCORTED BY SOME MEMBERS
RODRIGUEZ AND CERVANTES.
THE READER ME GUESS IS THE
CHAIRMAN AND CEO OF AND A GROUP
OF COMPANIES BETTER CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT.
INVENTOR DEVELOPMENT COMPANY
WHICH ALL NATIONAL LEADERS IN
REAL ESTATE.
READ OVERSEE SEVENTEEN OFFICES
AND A STAFF OF FOUR HUNDRED
TALENTED EXECUTIVES IS DOMINGUEZ
SERVES AS A DIRECTOR OF KATIE
HOLMES THE C. I. T. GROUP AND
BANC.
THE DOMAIN HAS DREAM FOUNDED IN
MEMORY OF HER FATHER EMPOWERS
CHILDREN AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO ACHIEVE AND
LITERACY AND STEM.
THE READERS ALSO PART OWNER OF
THE SACRAMENTO KINGS IT WAS
NAMED ONE OF THE FIFTY MOST
POWERFUL LATINOS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY
FORTUNE MAGAZINE. THREE ROWS
AWAY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
NOTRE DAME OF THE PS AND FINANCE
AND HOLD A CERTIFICATE AND
CORPORATE GOVERNANCE FROM
HARVARD UNIVERSITY.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A REPORT SHE BRITAIN
BUSINESS AND FOR LEVEL THREE THE
RANDOM MAGUS.
THE HONOREE FOR CHEAPER THAN
ACADEMIA'S ALBERT J. COVER RIO
HE IS ESCORTED BY SOMEBODY
MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA ROBERT
RIVAS AND SENATOR BOB ARCHER
LETTER -- CAMARENA WAS THE SON
OF LEON SLOSS JUNIOR THE MORE
YOU PROFESSOR AND PROFESSOR OF
AMERICAN HISTORY EMERITUS AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
HE IS WIDELY REGARDED AS ONE OF
THE FOUNDERS OF MEXICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CHICANO STUDIES.
HE IS THE FIRST MEXICAN AMERICAN
IN THE NATION'S HISTORY TO
RECEIVE A PHD IN US HISTORY WITH
A SPECIALIZATION IN CHICAGO
HISTORY.
HE IS ALSO KNOWN AS THE MALL
DEFICIT STORY AND AFTER SERVING
AFTER HAVING SERVICE EXPERT
WITNESS FOR SEVERAL VOTING
RIGHTS CASES IN CALIFORNIA
VIBRANT LATINO PLAINTIFFS.
HE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
COMPTON AND IS A LONG LIST OF
UCLA.
WELCOME OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A REPORT SHE
BUTTONED ACADEMIA ALBERT J.
COVER RIO.
THE HONOREE FORTY MINUTE PUBLIC
SERVICES THE LABOR FLORA SUB IT
SHE IS A SCOLDED BY SOME MEMBERS
EGGMAN AND GLORIA. TO LEYVA
FLOORS UP IT IS A RISING STAR IN
THE MOVEMENT FOR GENDER AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA AND THE REGION.
FLORA SUB IT IS THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESS CALIFORNIA OFFICE WHERE
SHE WORKS TO ENGAGE IN MOBILIZED
DIVERSE POPULATIONS TO BREAK THE
STIGMA SURROUNDING MENTAL HEALTH.
AND TO BECOME ADVOCATES AND
TEACHERS FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
ADDITION TO A PROFESSIONAL WORK
SHE FOUNDED THE STOCK IN YOUNGER
WOMEN STAFF SPORTS WHICH
COLLABORATED TO BRING.
THE FIRST EVER WOMEN'S MARCH TO
STOCKING ON JANUARY NINETEENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PLEASE
WELCOME TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ON A REPORTS EVEN A PUBLIC
SERVICE TO LABOR FLORA SUB IT.
THE ON A REPORT SHE EVEN IN
EDUCATION AND MEDIA IS CARLOS
CORTEZ HE IS ESCORTED BY SIMPLY
MEMBERS MEDINA AND REYES.
DR CARLOS HE CORTES IS PROFESSOR
EMERITUS OF HISTORY AT THAT YOU
SEE.
UC'S RIVERSIDE HE SPEAKS A
CONSULTS ON ISSUES OF DIVERSITY
AROUND THE GLOBE AND SERVES ON
THE FACULTIES OF SEVERAL
INSTITUTES AND ORGANIZATIONS
WERE TALES WAS A SCHOLAR IN
RESIDENCE WITH UNIVISION.
EVER SEE THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
IN DOUBLE ACP IMAGE AWARDS FOR
HIS WORK AS CREATIVE CULTURAL
ADVISER OF THE DORA THE EXPLORER
AND GO DIEGO GO.
HIS MANY BOOKS A CLUE IS MEMBER
OUR ROLES HILL IN INTERMARRIAGE
REPORTS TIME BEFORE GOING TO
MULTI CULTURAL AMERICA A
MULTIMEDIA ENCYCLOPEDIA.
WELCOME OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A REPORT SHE
ADMITTED EDUCATION AND MEDIA
CALLS CORTES.
WE ARE REPORTS EVEN IN BUSINESS
AND PHILANTHROPY IS ON HILL LVR
HE IS ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOCK OF RUBIO AND
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO.
I'M HILL DEL WE ARE IS THE
FOUNDER OF BILL RECORDS A
SUCCESSFUL LATIN INDEPENDENT
ENTERTAINMENT LABEL WHICH
REDEFINED THE REGIONAL MEXICAN
TO SUMMER MUSIC.
DEL RECORDS HAS THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY ARTISTS AND TWENTY THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION FANS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THE ROLE OF A
SURVEY OUR SUCCESS HE REMAINS
HUMBLE AND A STRONG ADVOCATE OF
GIVING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
AS HE REMEMBERS HIS CHALLENGE
UPBRINGING THE SURVEY ARE HAS
DONATED OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS AND
PROJECTS WELCOME OUR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ON A REPORT
SHE EVEN IN BUSINESS AND FOR
LEVEL.
THREE ON HILL THEY'LL PLAY ARE.
WE HONOR WE FOR DYNAMIC YOUTH IS
ANTHONY GONZALEZ HE IS ESCORTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND CENTER CABALLERO.
ANTHONY GONZALEZ IS GROWN UP
PERFORMING AND IN THE ARTS HE
VOICED THE LEAD ROLE OF MCGILL
PIXAR'S OSCAR WINNING ANIMATED
FEATURE COCOA TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH HE WON A TEEN
CHOICE AWARD.
HE ALSO STARRED IN THE
INDEPENDENT FEATURE ICE BOX
WHICH IS BASED ON DIRECTOR
DANIEL SARCOS SHORT FILM OF THE
DAY OF THE SAME NAME WHICH WON A
GRAND JURY PRIZE FOR LIVE ACTION
SHORT FILM IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN APR FEST
ANTHONY HAS A REOCCURRING ROLE
ON SHOWTIME'S SHAMELESS.
HE ALSO RECENTLY STARTED NBC
UNIVERSAL FEATURE GRANT AT A
DAYCARE WELCOME OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A REFER DYNAMIC YOU
ANTHONY GOOD SALAS.
THE ON EVERY FOR EXCELLENCE IN
FOR LAMPREY AS ANTONIA HERNANDEZ
SHE IS ESCORTED BY SOMEBODY
MEMBERS SANTIAGO LEóN IN THE
THREE OF US.
NATIONALLY REGARDED FOR HER
EXPERTISE AND IMMIGRATION CIVIL
RIGHTS OF PHILANTHROPY AND TO BE
A HERNANDEZ HAS SPENT MORE THAN
FOUR DECADES ADVOCATING FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
IN IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND BEYOND.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR SHE HAS
SERVED AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
ONE OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST AND MOST ACTIVE
PHILANTHROPISTS ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH IS SERVE ANGELENOS FOR
OVER A CENTURY.
THE FOUNDATION PARTNERS WITH
MORE THAN SIXTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY AND CORPORATE
DONORS AND HOLDS ASSETS OF MORE
THAN ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION.
WELCOME OUR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A REPORTS EVEN IF
PHILANTHROPY ANTONIA HERNANDEZ.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
ADVOCACY AND ENTERTAINMENT IS
CRYSTAL ALONSO SHE IS ESCORTED
BY SIMPLY MEMBERS CARILLO QUIRK
SILVA AND SENATOR HER TAUGHT ON
THE CELL ALONSO WAS THE FIRST
LATINA TO CREATE PRODUCE AND
STAR IN HER OWN.
NETWORK TV SITCOM THE STILLER
WHICH AIRED ON ABC.
THE SEMI BIOGRAPHICAL SHOW WAS
BASED ON HER TIME LIVING WITH
HER SISTER WHILE ALSO TAKING
CARE OF HER MOTHER.
THE STILLER PROBABLY HAD AN ALL
LATINO PRIMARY CASSON HIRED
NUMEROUS LATINO WRITERS FOR HER
SO.
SHE HAS MANY REOCCURRING HOST ON
THE VIEW.
SHE RECENTLY.
RELEASED HER FIRST SET UP
SPECIAL LOWER CLASS YOUR NETFLIX
AS WELL AS BECOMING THE FIRST
LATINO LEAD IN A DISNEY PIXAR
FILM WITH HER BREAK OUT ROLE AS
CREWS ARE MAYORS.
AND CARS THREE IN ADDITION TO
OUR WORK IN ENTERTAINMENT STILL
HAS DEVOTED A LARGE PART OF OUR
TIME. TO THE VOICE FOR LATINOS
IMMIGRANTS OF THE
DISENFRANCHISED AND THE UNDER
REPRESENTED.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON A RE FOR CHEAPER
THAN ADVOCACY AND ENTERTAINMENT
FOR CELL ALONSO.
WELL THANK YOU IF WE CAN I'LL
HAVE ANOTHER BIG ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR ALL OF ON A RECENT
DAY
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND GUESTS
TODAY WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST PRESENT TODAY.
IN THE REAR CHAMBER IS MISTER
RICHARD MONTOYA MISTER MONTEL IS
CO FOUNDER OF THE LEGENDARY
PERFORMANCE TRIO KNOWN AS
CULTURE CLASH.
KNOWN FOR HIS INSIGHTFUL WORK.
IN TWINED WITH SOCIAL JUSTICE IN
DEEPLY HUMAN PORTRAITS OF
AMERICANS IN THE MARGINS OF
SOCIETY.
TôI IS ALSO A FILMMAKER OF
AWARD WINNING WORKS INCLUDING
WATER AND POWER AND YET TO BE
RELEASED DOCUMENTARY CARLOS --
AS ARE A NUMBER US.
PLAYING WITH FIRE.
HE IS THE SON OF SACRAMENTO POET
LAUREATE JOSE MONTOYA AND
EDUCATOR MARY ELLEN MONTOYA.
THIS WOMAN TOYOTA IS A FIERCE
ARTS ADVOCATE ACTIVIST AUTHOR
AND PROUD FATHER OF MOUNTAIN IN
MOVIE LUNA LUCIA.
AGES EIGHT AND SIX MONTHS PLEASE
JOIN HIM JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
HIM TO THE FLOOR THIS.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME
OTHER SPECIAL GUESTS WHO JOINED
US IN OBSERVANCE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENDANCE WE ENCOURAGE OUR
VISITORS AND GUESTS TO VIEW THE
SPECIAL EXHIBIT IN THE CAPITAL
SECOND FLOOR ROTUNDA.
IN HONOR OF THOSE WHO A SPEAR
HONOREES ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF LATINO CAUCUS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION THIS
CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY SECOND READING.
CIRCLE RATE.
SOME PEOPLE 1-829-125-2602
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE FOURTEEN HUNDRED FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN OH SEVEN TEN FIFTY
THREE FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TO AVOID WITH A
MEMBERS THIRTEEN OH FOR THE
MEMBERS 295-182-21590 FIVE THE
MINUTES. TEN SIXTY TWO WITH A
MOMENT SEVEN TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WITH A MEMBERS THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE WITH A MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN WITH A
MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE A NAME READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS.
TWENTY TWO THROUGH TWENTY SIX
PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB FIVE
TWENTY BY MISTER KALRA CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE TWENTY BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA ACCOLADE THE
PUBLIC WORKS.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIVE
TWENTY WHICH DEFINES WHEN A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF DETERMINING IF
THE PREVAILING WAGE APPLIES TO
PRIVATE PROJECTS.
USING PUBLIC FUNDS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC
SAYS SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE
PROJECT AS DE MINIMUS SO LONG AS
IT IS LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND LESS THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE PROJECT IS
NOT SUBJECT VALLEY WAGE LAW EVEN
IF IT RECEIVES A PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
IF THAT SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE PROJECT.
SINCE THE TERM DE MINIMUS IS NOT
DEFINED IN STATUTE THERE IS NO
GUIDANCE AS TO THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL PUBLIC SUBSIDY THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED.
THE MENACE.
THIS IS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO MAKE
INCONSISTENT RULINGS AS TO WHAT
IS DE MINIMUS LEADING TO
CONFUSION AND LITIGATION.
A PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR A PRIVATE
PROJECT THAT IS MORE THIS TO AN
ATTORNEY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR 2% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST
AS A NOTABLE TAXPAYER INVESTMENT.
AND IT IS REASONABLE TO REQUIRE
PREVAILING WAGES OF THE
DEVELOPER WANTS PUBLIC SUBSIDY
OVER THAT AMOUNT.
UNDER THIS BILL NO DEVELOPERS
REQUIRED TO TAKE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
OVER THE DE MINIMUS AMOUNT IF
THEY DO NOT WANT TO PAY THE
PREVAILING WAGE.
UPHOLDING NOT UPHOLDING ARE
PREVAILING WAGE LAWS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ENSURE
THAT CONTRACTORS ARE NOT AWARDED
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS BY VIRTUE
OF PAYING LOW WAGES AND UNDER
UNDER CUTTING RESPONSIBLE
COMPETITORS.
AB FIVE TWENTY WELL CLEARLY
DEFINED WHEN A PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
TO MINIMUS. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETERMINING WHEN PREVAILING
WAGES APPLIED TO PROP PRIOR
PROJECTS WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE FIFTY ONE
KNOWS.
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT IS AB FOR
NINETY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF A
MENACE CORKERY WITH MINUTES.
SOME PEOPLE FOR NINETY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS VICE MEMBER BELOW.
SURE LOW ON THE MINUTES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY SIX WITH TECHNICAL
MINUTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LOW WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE FILE ITEMS TWENTY NINE
THROUGH THIRTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT IS AB
FIFTEEN TEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
TEN WITH A MINUTES BY SOME THE
MEMORY IS.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
OR TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT FILE ITEMS THIRTY
NINE THROUGH FORTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR AB SIXTY ONE MY
MEASURE TANK CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER TING AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE FIREARMS MR TING EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER B
SIXTY ONE IS MY BILL TO EXPAND
THE GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER.
GOODBYE INTEREST TRAINING ORDERS
RIGHT NOW CAN BE USED.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OR BY A
FAMILY MEMBER TO PETITION THE
COURT TO TAKE SOMEBODY'S
FIREARMS TEMPORARILY AWAY.
WE'VE BEEN POSING THAT THIS
EXPANDED THE SHOULD BE EXPANDED
TO YOUR COWORKERS YOUR EMPLOYERS
AS WELL AS TEACHERS AND
PRINCIPALS BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE SEEN QUITE TOO OFTEN.
SITUATIONS HAPPEN AT SCHOOL AND
AT WORK WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN
PUBLIC SAFETY TO NARROW IT A
LITTLE MORE.
SO THAT ANYBODY WHO IS A TEACHER
AND A PRINCIPAL OR AN EMPLOYEE
OR AN EMPLOYER YOUR HOW TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH HUMAN RESOURCES.
TO ENSURE THAT THEY WERE -- IN
FOR INFORMING THAT INDIVIDUAL IN
ALLOWING THAT INDIVIDUAL THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE DIALOGUE
BEFORE PETITIONING THE COURT.
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS SINCE
THE GUN BONTA STRENUOUS HAVE
BEEN EXISTENCE THERE BEEN SIX
WHOLE OVER.
SIX HUNDRED GB ARE OWES ISSUE.
MANY OF THEM IN SAN DIEGO THANKS
TO THE HARD WORK OF CITY
ATTORNEY.
MAR ELITE HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT
INDIVIDUALS WERE GETTING THEIR
GUNS TEMPORARILY TAKEN AWAY.
I KNOW THAT WHEN WE FIRST
PROPOSED THIS THERE WAS A
CONCERN THAT THIS EXPANSION OR
EVEN THIS INITIAL LAW WOULD LEAD
TO A THOUSANDS OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DVR OWES TO BE
ISSUE BUT AGAIN.
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT THESE ARE
BEING ISSUE VERY STRATEGICALLY --
WITH SIX SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FOG AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
EXPANSION WILL AGAIN JUST A
POWER PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAYBE SHOULDN'T
HAVE GUNS AS WELL AS GO TO
SCHOOL WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
SHOULDN'T HAVE GUNS WITHOUT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE ON A.
B..
SIXTY ONE THE FAMOUS TANK.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SHOULD BE
THREE NOS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS RUNNING BACK GOING TO GO
BACK TO FILE ITEM. THIRTY EIGHT
FOR WHICH WE PASS TEMPORARILY
THIS IS AB.
FIFTEEN TEN BY MISS REYES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN TEN WITH THE
PAYMENTS BY SOME MEMORY IS.
MS RACE ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE AB. FIFTEEN TOWN IS UP TODAY
FOR PURPOSES OF A MAN AT THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES THESE ARE
MOMENTS WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT TO
PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FORTY AB.
NINE TWENTY COOKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINE TWENTY BY SOME
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND
ACCOLADES ROCKING ALCOHOL
PROGRAMS THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
NINE TWENTY THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO PROTECT PATIENTS WHO
ARE IN RECOVERY FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT.
THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
CALIFORNIA'S OF AMERICA AS A
CRISIS IS STAGGERING ACCORDING
TO THE CDC HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PEOPLE DIED IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE LIGHTS EACH AND EVERY DAY
THIS NOW MAKES OPIOIDS A TOP
FIVE CAUSE OF DEATH HERE IN
AMERICA.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING AND AT
SEEMINGLY EVERY STEP WE HAVE A
HANDFUL OF BAD ACTORS AND
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS WHO ARE
PROFITEERING FROM THIS CRISIS.
THIS SPELL ADDRESSES THAT
CRITICAL NEED FOR APPROPRIATELY
APPROPRIATE LICENSING AND
OVERSIGHT OF FOR PROFIT DRUG
REHABILITATION CENTERS.
WELL THEY'RE A GOOD ACTORS THAT
ARE DOING POSITIVE WORK FOR
THOSE SEEKING RECOVERY
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING PATIENTS TO REAP HIGH
PROFITS.
THE HORROR STORY PLAYS OUT TIME
AND AGAIN THE PATIENT IS
RECRUITED FROM OUT OF STATE BY A
BODY BROKER.
OUT OF NETWORK INSURANCE
POLICIES ARE PURCHASED FOR THE
PATIENT AND RUN UP HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
AFTER THIRTY SIXTY OR NINETY
DAYS WHEN INSURANCE RENT
INSURANCE RUNS OUT.
THE PATIENT IS CURVED
EXACERBATING CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
SOMETIMES PATIENTS ARE EVEN
ENCOURAGED TO RELAPSE IN ORDER
FOR THE CYCLE TO BEGIN AGAIN.
THE CYCLE IS ONLY POSSIBLE TO
YOU TO A TOTAL LACK OF
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT IN THIS
AREA. EIGHTY NINE TWENTY AIMS TO
ADDRESS THE COMMERCIAL INCENTIVE
DRIVING THESE UNSCRUPULOUS
OPERATORS SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY CLARIFIES.
THAT A TREATMENT FACILITY FOR
SIX OR FEWER PATIENTS WHEN IT'S
PART OF A LARGER BUSINESS AND
CORPORATE NETWORK I E. INTERN
ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIP.
IT IS A BUSINESS AND NOT A
RESIDENTIAL HOME.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT IT IS TIME
FOR US TO ENACT THE SAME
LEGISLATIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
PEOPLE BATTLING ADDICTION.
THAT ARE IN PLACE FOR PEOPLE
FACING SO MANY OTHER MEDICAL
CHALLENGE AS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE IT.
THANK YOU MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OF EIGHT
I'M SORRY MR DAILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT
ADDRESSES A VERY PROBLEMATIC
ISSUE.
THE BILL WILL HELP ROOT OUT THE
BAD ACTORS WHO PROFIT BY
EXPLOITING PEOPLE IN RECOVERY.
IN ALCOHOL OR DRUG ADDICTION
RECOVERY THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE IT'S GREAT BILL.
FAMOUS DALY SAYING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A AYE AYES.
SIXTY TWO KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN FILE ITEM FORTY SIX IS AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO BY MISS WICKS
CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO BY
SOME MEMORABLE RICKSON ACCOLADE
THE CRIMES MS WICKS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL ALLOW
COURTS TO REQUIRE AN ALTERNATIVE
COMMUNITY SERVICE OPTION OTHER
THAN LITTER PICK UP WHEN A
PERSON IS CONVICTED OF LITTERING
IN A BODY OF WATER.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILLS PROVIDE
COURTS FLEXIBILITY AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON THE
COMMUNITIES NEEDS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR CHILL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE QUESTION
THIS WAY.
SO WHAT.
SEC.
IS THIS YOUR FIRST BILL.
THIS IS MY FIRST BILL SO WHY I
READ YOUR PROPOSAL I KNOW THE
CURRENT LAW SAYS THE PUNISHMENT
SHOULD FIT THE CRIME IF YOU'RE
FOUND GUILTY OF ILLEGAL DUMPING.
YOU SHOULD PICK UP LITTER AND
YOU'RE PROPOSING TO CHANGE THAT.
WHICH REDEFINES JUSTICE I THINK
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF JUSTICES
STRIKES ME AS A KIND OF
VIGILANTE JUSTICE IMPOSED BY.
A VAMPIRE SLAYER.
SO MY QUESTION IS ARE YOU A
VAMPIRE SLAYER.
AND IS YOUR NAME REALLY BUFFY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO ACROSS THE BAY AND
I KNOW YOU AND I ARE IN MANY
MANY BILLS TOGETHER SO YOU WILL
BE HAPPY TO KNOW THAT.
INDEED BUFFY'S MY REAL NAME AND
I AM A SLAYER.
MR CHIU COLLEAGUES IN EVERY
GENERATION THERE IS A CHOSEN.
ONE AND I THINK THAT ARE THE
STATE COLLEGES THAT SHOWS AND
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I LOOK FOR
SUPPORTING IT AND ASK YOU ALL TO
VOTE I THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
VAMPIRE ENQUIRIES.
MS WHICH SHE MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIRED BUT I CITY FIVE
KNOWS.
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN FILE
ITEMS FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY IS A. B. SIX OH FIVE
COOKERY.
SO MIDDLE SIX OH FIVE BISON
REMAINED SHINING OTHERS
INOCULATE ESPECIALISTA CATION
MISS MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX OH FIVE
GUARANTEES THAT A STUDENT WHO
REQUIRES AN ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY
DEVICE.
HAS TE RIGHT TO USE THAT DEVICE
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL HOURS OF
DETERMINE NECESSARY BY THEIR I
EP.
THESE DEVICES ARE IMPORTANT
TOOLS TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNICATE LEARN
AND INTERACT WITH THEIR
ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF THEM.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO IS AB SIX
NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY FIVE BY
SOME RIVER MEDINA ACCOLADE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES MISTER MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB SIX
NINETY FIVE EXTENDS THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
SIGN BILLS STATUTE UNTIL.
TWENTY THIRTY ACCORDING TO
EXPERIENCES FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS THEY USE
DESIGNED BUILT CONTRACTING TO
EXPEDIA EIGHT THE CONSTRUCTION
OF A PROJECT.
AVOID CONFLICTS BETWEEN
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS AND
CONTRACTORS AND REDUCE COSTS.
AMENDMENTS RECENTLY ADOPTED
APPLY EXISTING PROVISIONS
REGARDING THE USE OF A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE BILL.
COR CLUB THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE IS AB.
SEVEN OH SIX YES AB SEVEN OH SIX
CORKERY.
SO MIDDLE SEVEN OH SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN ZERO
SIX ALLOWS FACULTY MEMBERS IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO ACCESS THE BENEFITS
WITH OUT ADDITIONAL BEARS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISS LOW SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLICK LOCAL.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS WHAT IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY FOUR PASS RETAIN FILE
ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB NINE TWENTY
THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER WICKS AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTRICITY.
THE SWITCH TO MAKE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB AT NINE TWENTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW BART THE BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT SYSTEM TO PURCHASE
ELECTRICITY.
DIRECTLY FROM HIGH SO WHOLESALE
MARKETS.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT BILL --
FOR FOR REGIONAL AS A REGIONAL
MEASURE AND FOR THE HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION RIDES THAT PART
IS CURRENTLY.
A SERVE IN THE SYSTEM THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HAS NO STATE COSTS AND IN FACT
WOULD SAVE PART BETWEEN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE AIM IS WICKS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX IS AB.
NINE TWENTY NINE BY MS THREE OF
US CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINE TWENTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER THREE OF US AUSTIN
ACCOLADES HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
THREE OF US YOU MAY OPEN --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M EXCITED TO PRESENT
AB NINE TWO NINE WHICH INSURERS
COVER CALIFORNIA HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT THE DATA IT
NEEDS TO FULLY EVALUATE HOW
HEALTH PLAN.
IS DELIVERING CARE AND TO
PUBLISH THAT DATA BY HEALTH PLAN --
SPECIFICALLY CUTTER COVER
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE WILL BE ABLE
TO SEE WHICH PLANS ARE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS LAUREN COST
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AND IMPROVING OVERALL HEALTH
CARE QUALITY PUBLISHING THE
STATE OF MY HEALTH PLAN WILL
EMPOWER PATIENTS TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS RELATED TO THEIR
HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
BY ALLOWING THEM TO CHOOSE THE
BEST HEALTH PLAN FOR THEM.
THE PROCESS TO ELIMINATING
HEALTH DISPARITIES INEQUITY
STARTS WITH HIGH QUALITY DATA
AND AB NINETY NINE IS THE FIRST
STEP -- THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
TAKING HIS RIVAS.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I SIX
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN IS AB NINE
THIRTY TWO BY MISTER LOWE
CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE A WORKERS COMPENSATION.
MR LOW YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN A GUNMAN OPENED FIRE
AT THE ROUTE NINETY ONE HARVEST
FESTIVAL IN LAS VEGAS
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
BRAVEST FIREFIGHTERS WERE SHOT
IN THE COURSE OF RENDERING AID
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS WERE NOT ABLE.
TO ACCESS WORKERS COMPENSATION
THIS BILL ALLOWS -- FOR PARITY
AND ENSURING THAT OUR PREVIOUS
ARE ALSO PROTECTED WHEN THEY PUT
THEIR LIVES AT RISK EACH AND
EVERY DAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISS LOWEST FLORA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A GREAT BILL
TO SUPPORT OF FIREFIGHTERS THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO PROTECT US
EVERYDAY.
WHEN THEY'RE OFF DUTY AND THEIR
SUPPORT NOT US IT'S THE LEAST WE
CAN DO TO GIVE THE PROTECTION
THAT THEY NEED IF THEY'RE
INJURED?
ON THE IN THE LINE OF DUTY -- IN
OFF THE LINE OF DUTY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
THANK YOU.
NAME IS FLOOR SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS.
ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM.
FIFTY EIGHT AB NINE SEVENTY FIVE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME THE RIVER CALDERON ACCOLADE
TO ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA ADAPTATION LEADERSHIP
AND COORDINATION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES STATES.
EL REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE AND
SUB NATIONAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SUPPORT AND PROMOTE THE STATE'S
GOALS AND POLICIES RELATING TO
OCEAN COASTAL AND TO WRESTLE
ADAPTATION AND WOULD REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY TO TAKE ALL ACTIONS
NECESSARY WHEN COLLABORATING
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES -- AND SOME
NATIONAL GOVERNMENTS RELATED TO
ACCOMPLISHING THOSE GOALS AND
POLICIES AS PRESCRIBED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK GLOBAL ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES.
FIFTY FOUR KNOW SOMEONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO RETURN TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible] FORTY SEVEN THIS IS
A. B. TWO NINE TWO FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN AB TWO NINETY TWO BY
DR QUIRK CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACCOLADE
TO WATER [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
TWO NINETY TWO WILL CLARIFY THE
TERMS USED FOR RECYCLED WATER.
A GIVEN THE VARIOUS POSSIBLE
TYPES OF RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS
A COMMON SET OF TERMS.
WILL ASSIST THE WATER AGENCIES
WHEN PROMOTING THE SAFE USE OF
RECYCLED WATER.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME ARRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF EL
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES BACK N REGULAR
FILE ORDER WORD FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE AB TEN NINETY CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY BY SOME
WE WERE MEDINA AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC -- SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHT TEN NINETY
WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES OR UNIVERSITIES TO
WAIVE ANY MANDATORY CAMPUS BASED
FEES FOR THE SURVIVING SPOUSES
AND OR CHILDREN OF DECEASED LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS.
CAMPUS BASED FEES ARE APPROVED
AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND VERY
AMONG CON CAMPUSES AND CAN BE UP
TO THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK WAS MEDINA AND SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
GLOBAL ROLE.
IT IS OUT OF AT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THERE IS AT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY PASS
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY ONE A. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN CLOCK RATE.
SO MAYBE ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR VICE
WILL BE REMAIN SHINING ACCOLADE
TO EMPLOYEE SAFETY IN DECLARE
THE YEARS EITHER OF TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
WILL REQUIRE THE OSHA BOARD TO
ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS --
FOR EMPLOYERS TO MAKE
RESPIRATORS AVAILABLE TO OUTDOOR
WORKERS ON ANY DAY THEY WOULD
RECENTLY EXPOSED TO HARMFUL
LEVELS OF WILD FIRE SMOKE.
CALIFORNIA'S EPIDEMIC OF DEADLY
WILDFIRES CONTINUES TO WORSEN
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WORK
OUTDOORS AND RISK EXPOSURE TO
HAZARDS PRESENTED BY WILD FIRE
SMOKE.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE -- IN THIS
REGARD SO I THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROOM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE BILL THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO IS AB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE BY MISTER SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY ONE
BY SOME MEMBERS SANTIAGO
ACCOLADE TO CIVIL PROCEDURE.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWELVE FIFTY ONE
WOULD READ BUT WOULD REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE OF TIME LINES WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL IS SEEKING JUDICIAL
REVIEW I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
NEITHER.
FAMOUS SON THIAGO SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF WE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSER
RETAIN PART ME YES PASS RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM.
SIXTY THREE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN
ACCOLADE TO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR THE OPTION PERCENT THIS BILL
TODAY EIGHT BE TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION FROM ASSISTING.
OR ALLOWING PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS TO ARREST DETAIN OR
OTHERWISE TAKE INTO CUSTODY
INDIVIDUALS IN STATE CUSTODY FOR
IMMIGRATION PURPOSES.
THE RESPONSE OF THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS MASSIVE
DETENTION AND DEPORTATION
STRATEGY.
THE THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS
RELYING HEAVILY ON THE USE OF
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW.
THIS INCLUDES THE UNLAWFUL
AUTHRIZATION PROVIDE A PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS TO TAKE INTO
CUSTODY DETAIN AND ARREST
IMMIGRANTS TO SECURE THEIR RIGHT
TO RELEASE.
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS.
THIS IS IN DIRECT CONTRAVENTION
OF ESTABLISH FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS WELL AS WELL ESTABLISHED
LEGAL PRECEDENT.
FEDERAL LAW IS CLEAR.
UNDER THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AND NATIONALITY ACT AND ITS
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS ARE NOT AUTHORIZED
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAW.
SPONSORED BY ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE AS SUPPORTED
BY THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING A
MEASURE TAKES THE IMPORTANT STEP
THE MINISTER TO ENSURING THAT
CDC ARE COMPLIES A FEDERAL LAW.
BY PROHIBITING PRIVATE SECURITY
CONTRACTORS ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS FOR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF IT IS OUR ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE IS AB FORTINO.
SEVEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN ACRYLATE
TO VEHICLES.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU TODAY HAVE MEMBERS I
BRING YOU AB FORTINO SEVEN THIS
IS RESPONDING TO A GROWING
PROBLEM IN MY DISTRICT AND MANY
OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND THAT IS ILLEGAL STREET
RACING.
AND ALSO RECKLESS DRIVING.
NOW STREET RACING.
IS ALREADY ILLEGAL AND YET A
GROWING PROBLEM AND I WOULD
CONTEND BECAUSE THE PENALTIES
THAT WE HAVE DON'T ALWAYS
ADDRESS.
THE REAL ROOT OF PEOPLE'S DESIRE
TO DO STREET RACING FOR MONETARY
REWARD SO RIGHT NOW THE FINES
THAT PEOPLE GET IF YOU TALK TO
ANYBODY IN LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
JUST NOT ENOUGH OF A DETERRENT.
AND IN ADDITION THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE CURRENT LAW THAT REQUIRES
ILLEGAL MODIFICATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE TO VEHICLES TO BE
REMOVED BEFORE THE CARS RETURN.
NOW RECKLESS DRIVING ISN'T JUST
ROLLING THROUGH A STOP SIGN BY
ACCIDENT OR MAKING ANY LEGAL
RIGHT HAND TURN.
RECKLESS DRIVING IS DRIVING WITH
A WANTON DISREGARD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IT'S A CRIMINAL
MISDEMEANOR CHARGE.
MY BILL SAYS THAT ON THE SECOND
CONVICTION OF STREET RACING OR
RECKLESS DRIVING YOUR CAR WILL
BE IMPOUNDED BY FOR THIRTY DAYS.
TAKING AWAY.
PEOPLE'S WEAPON OF CHOICE IN
THESE CASES.
NOW THERE'S A LOT ABOUT FOR
JUDGES IF IT'S A CAR THAT HAS TO
BE USED FOR SOMEBODY TO GET TO
WORK OR IF THE CARS BEING DRIVEN
BY SOMEBODY'S CHILD.
AND LOTS OF OTHER REASONS OF
IT'S A HARDNESS ON THE FAMILY.
BUT WHEN WHAT I THOUGHT WHEN I
TALK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OF MY
DISTRICT THEY SAY THAT THE ONLY
THING THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ENGAGING IN THIS ACTIVITY CARE
ABOUT.
IS LOSING THAT VEHICLE FOR AN
FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
APPROACH THAT WILL WORK.
AND IT'S ONE THAT'S NEEDED JUST
A FEW WEEKS AGO WE HAD ANOTHER
CHILD KILLED BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL
STREET RACING WE HAVE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING THERE'S CARNAGE ON OUR
STREETS.
DRIVING IS A PRIVILEGE NOT A
RIGHT.
AND PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO RESPECT
AGAIN THIS IS ON THE SECOND
CONVICTION.
WITH THAT NUMBER SO I WOULD
REQUEST FULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THERE WAS FRIEDMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION BAY.
CLARK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SIX FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SEVEN IS AB FIFTEEN OH
FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH FOUR BY
SOME MEMBER MEDINA AND ACCOLADES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTEEN ZERO FOUR DUE TO LACK OF
RESOURCES THE STUDENTS SENATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE VIRTUALLY NO
PRESENCE IN THE STATE CAPITAL.
AND LITTLE TO NO ABILITY TO
ADVOCATE FOR LEGISLATION THAT
AFFECTS CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AB EIGHT FIFTEEN OH FOUR WILL
ENSURE THAT A TWO DOLLARS
STUDENT REGISTRATION FEE.
IS IMPLEMENTED AT ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY COLLECTING
IT FROM STUDENTS UPON PAYMENT A
REGISTRATION FEES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
AN EQUAL VOICE WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICIES AND LEGISLATION THAT
IMPACTS THEM.
LIKE THE CSU STUDENTS AND THE
STUDENTS OF UC.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL IDEA CAME FROM THE
STUDENT LEADERS THEMSELVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK WAS MEDINA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
USER TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICT
THREE KNOWS TWELVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT FILE ITEM.
SIXTY NINE IS AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SUMMER BLOOM AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE OF PESTICIDES MR
BELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES REPORTED THAT THE
MOUNTAIN LION.
KNOWN AS P. -- FORTY SEVEN FROM
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS HAD
DIED DUE TO ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE POISONING.
IN FACT HE HAD TESTED POSITIVE
FOR SIX DIFFERENT CHEMICALS
FOUND IN THESE WROTE DOWN THE
SIDES.
P. FORTY SEVEN HOWEVER IT WAS
ONE OF ONLY FIFTEEN MOUNTAIN
LIONS THAT CALL THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS HOME.
BUT WAS OF THOSE FIFTEEN THE
FOURTH ONE ABOUT SENSITIVE
POPULATION IT HAS DIED DIRECTLY
AS A RESULT.
OF RODENTICIDE POISONING.
IN FACT TESTING IS SHOWN THAT
NEARLY EVERY MOUNTAIN LION HAS
RAT POISON IN THEIR SYSTEM.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER TOP LEVEL
PREDATORS AND WILDLIFE THAT HAVE
BEEN POISONED AND KILLED.
AND ACROSS THE STATE MANY CASES
WHERE PETS OF BEEN POISONED
AFTER INGESTING THESE CHEMICALS.
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDE THIS
BECAUSE ANIMALS TO BLEED OUT
INTERNALLY AND THIS ALSO
DISRUPTS THEIR IMMUNE SYSTEMS
NATURAL ABILITY TO FIGHT OFF
INFECTIONS AND AFFLICTIONS SUCH
AS MANGE WHICH ULTIMATELY IS THE
DISEASE THAT TAKES MANY OF THESE
ANIMALS.
IN THE THREE MAJOR MOUNTAIN LINE
STUDIES CURRENTLY BEING
CONDUCTED IN CALIFORNIA
RODENTICIDE HAVE APPEARED IN
EVERY TISSUE SAMPLE TAKEN FROM
WILD ADULT LIONS AT LEVELS HIGH
ENOUGH TO BE OF SERIOUS CONCERN.
ANOTHER STUDY REGARDING THE
ENDANGERED PACIFIC FISHER HAS
SHOWN THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS AND
THREATS THAT RODENTICIDE POSE
AND IT'S CAN CONTRIBUTION TO
THAT SPECIES NEAR EXTINCTION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE HAS BEEN WARNING ABOUT
THE IMPACTS THAT ROSANNA SITES
ARE HAVING ON ALL WILDLIFE IN
THE STATE AND AS A RESULT OF
THESE WARNINGS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION REGULATION
ENACTED REGULATIONS TO RESTRICT
THE USE OF SECOND GENERATION
ANTI COAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
IN THE HOPES OF DECREASING THE
NON TARGETED DEATHS BUT THESE
REGULATIONS HAVE NOT RESULTED IN
A DECREASE IN SECONDARY WILDLIFE
POISONINGS.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE STAYED
CONSTANT OR IN SOME CASES
INCREASED.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF SECOND
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO
PROHIBITS THE USE OF FIRST
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE.
ON STATE OWNED PROPERTY WITH
EXEMPTIONS FOR AGRICULTURAL AND
FOOD PROCESSING USES.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE MEANS OF
CONTROLLING RODENT POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING
SUCCESSFULLY IS BY THE PET
MANAGEMENT.
INDUSTRY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DAVIS BLOOM DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I
DON'T OFTEN GET UP ON THE FLOOR
TO SUPPORT OTHER PEOPLE'S BILLS --
BUT I'M MAKING AN EXCEPTION HERE
I MAKE AN EXCEPTION BECAUSE I
CARE.
ABOUT OUR ENVIRONMENT THE CARE
ABOUT THE RAPTORS THE MOUNTAIN
LIONS THE COYOTES.
WE HAVE AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION RATS.
WHICH POINTS OUT THAT BY KILLING
THE MOUNTAIN LIONS WITH THESE
RODENTICIDE BY KILLING.
THE RAPTOR WE ARE LIMITING THE
WAYS WE CONTROL THE ROADS IN THE
WILD.
THIS IS TRULY SOMETHING THAT
OUGHT TO HIT THE HEART SPRINGS
HEART STRINGS OF EVERYONE HERE.
AND I'M HOPING IT DOES BECAUSE
WE HAVE GOOD SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE THAT THIS IS HARMING
OUR WILDLIFE.
AND IT HAS TO STOP NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT QUIRK.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT JUST
YESTERDAY THE U. N. REPORTED
THAT.
APPROXIMATELY A MILLION SPECIES
ON THE EARTH ARE ON THE VERGE OF
EXTINCTION DUE TO YOU.
THE ACTIVITY OF HUMAN BEINGS.
I LIVE IN THE HILLS IN GLENDALE.
AND WHEN I SEE COYOTES IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S VERY VERY
COMMON.
THAT THEY ARE CLEARLY SUFFERING
FROM THE EFFECTS OF ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
ANIMALS SPOTTED AROUND THE AREA
WITH MANGE.
THIN.
SUFFERING WEEK.
WE SEE DEAD HAWKS AND OWLS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
I REPRESENT GRIFFITH PARK.
MOUNTAIN LIONS DYING.
BECAUSE OF RODENTICIDE HAS
BECOME A HUGE AREA OF CONCERN.
FROM THE PUBLIC THE PUBLIC WHO
DOESN'T WANT TO SEE OUR WILDLIFE
BEING POP POISON NEEDLESSLY.
I HEARD A VERY INTERESTING
REPORT FROM I BELIEVE IT WAS
FROM THE CITY OF OXNARD OR
SOMEWHERE IN VENTURA WHERE THEY
HAD DONE A STUDY.
WHERE THEY TOOK AN AREA THAT WAS
A SENSITIVE AREA BECAUSE OF RATS
AND THEY TOOK TO PARTS AND THEY
WERE VERY CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE YOU KNOW
BASICALLY IDENTICAL AREAS?
AND ONE AREA THEY USE THE
RODENTICIDE AND ANOTHER AREA
THEY USED RAPTORS JUST BY
PUTTING A RAPTURE HOUSE UP IN A
RAFTER MOVED IN.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND WAS AND THEY
WERE DONE ASIDE AREA.
THE RATS ACTUALLY THE POPULATION
OF RIGHTS ACTUALLY INCREASED
BECAUSE WHEN THE RATS DID EAT
THE ROAD UNDECIDED POISON THE
RAPTORS AND THE RAPTORS DIED.
THE AREA THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE
CHEMICALS THAT WAS USING ONLY
THE RAPTORS SAW A DRAMATIC
DECREASE IN THE RAP POPULATION.
SO NOT ONLY IS THIS CHEMICAL
CRUEL AND CAUSING HAVOC AMONGST
THE WILDLIFE THAT WE WANT TO
PRESERVE.
BUT IT'S COUNTERPRODUCTIVE NO I
HAVE SEEN THE BILL THE BILL HAS.
SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS FOR MEDICAL
EMERGING -- FOR FOR EMERGENCIES
ABOUT COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND
IN CERTAIN PLACES IT'S A VERY
BALANCED APPROACH.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS FOR MY COMMUNITY.
I HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF EMAILS OF
SUPPORT FROM CONSTITUENTS I HOPE
THAT YOU HAVE AS WELL IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU WILL
JOIN ME AND DOCTOR QUIRK OF
COURSE WERE MISSED -- THE MEMBER
FROM SANTA MONICA IN VOTING FOR
THIS MEASURE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE HIS LONG TIME WORK ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THERE WAS FRIEDMAN MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THAT WE HAD THIS BILL AND THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE AND I THINK THE BOTTOM
LINE IS ALTHOUGH I THINK THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS BILL IS A
GOOD -- ONE AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THE GENTLEMAN FROM --
WEST HOLLYWOOD WHAT HE'S TRYING
TO DO -- BUT IT IS TOO OVER
BROAD AND AS WE HEARD FROM MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS FIELD -- IF IF
YOU TOTALLY BAN THIS PRODUCT.
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE A VERY
VITAL TOOL IN GETTING THAT
RODENTS WHICH DO YOU KERRY
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
WHICH WILL HAVE IMPACTS IN OUR
IN OUR URBAN AND OUR RURAL AREAS --
RAPTORS ARE GREAT BUT THEY CAN'T
DO THE JOB ALONE -- AND SO THE
ISSUE HERE IS.
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO TAKE OUT
COMPLETELY ESSENTIALLY A PRODUCT.
THAT IS USED TO HELP KEEP DOWN
DISEASE TO KEEP ROAD RODENTS AND
OTHER -- VARMINTS FROM SPREADING
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND AGAIN ON TOP OF THIS WE
HEARD FROM THE PROFESSIONALS WHO
USES ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS THEY
USE IT CAREFULLY.
THEY USE IT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THAT
PRODUCT.
THESE ARE PROFESSIONALS WHO DO
THIS DOES THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT SHOULD BE MAKING THAT
DECISION.
NOT THOSE OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO DON'T HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE.
AND SO I'D ASK YOU TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THIS I THINK THIS
BILL IS IS WAY TOO OVER BROAD --
ESSENTIALLY COULD PUT THE WHOLE
INDUSTRY OUT OF BUSINESS -- AND
TAKE A VITAL PRODUCT TOLD OUT OF
PRODUCTION THAT WE DO NEED. TO
HELP WITH THESE WITH A VITAL
ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITY SO I
WOULD ASK YOU TO VOTE NO PLEASE.
MR VOEPEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I SELDOM GET UP TO SPEAK.
LIKE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM HAYWARD.
BUT I MUST TELL YOU.
THAT I HAVE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
TAKE ON THIS I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL EVEN AGAINST
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
A BIG GIVEN TO ME AND I'LL TELL
YOU WHY.
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE FINDING OUT AND PLEASE YOU
KNOW GOOGLE OR WHATEVER YOU GOT
TO DO.
CHECK MY NUMBERS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
IS IN THE MARIJUANA FIELDS THAT
ARE BEING CULTIVATED ILLEGALLY
BY CARTELS UP IN THE EMERALD
TRIANGLE.
THAT.
THEY ARE USING THESE COAGULANT
AND OTHER ILLICIT.
POISONS TO KILL THE RODENTS THAT
HAPPENED A LIKE TO EAT.
THE MARIJUANA PLANTS AND GET
HIGHER WHATEVER THEY'RE DOING
[inaudible]
NOW.
PLEASE GOOGLE THIS BUT IT LOOKS
TO ME.
LIKE THE SPOTTED OWL POPULATION
IS DROPPED 31%.
AND MANY OF THESE RAPTORS ARE
DYING.
BECAUSE THEY'RE EATING THE
RODENTS THAT HAVE BEEN POISONED.
BY.
ALL SORTS OF CHEMICALS SOME
GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BASED UPON THOSE CONCLUSIONS
I'VE DRAWN AND I HOPE YOU ALL.
MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE
DRAW THE SAME CONCLUSIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS VOEPEL.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM FOR THE BODY.
MR BLOOM YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SIR THANK
YOU FOR THE THE DEBATE THERE ARE
MANY ADDITIONAL OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO PEST CONTROL.
COMPANIES AND AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT IS SUPPORTED BY
MORE THAN SIXTY WILDLIFE GROUPS
INCLUDING SEVERAL SEVERAL
WILDLIFE RESCUE GROUP TO SEE THE
CARNAGE THAT IS CAUSED BY.
ROAD GENOCIDES ON A DAILY BASIS --
BASIS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS BLOOM WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VERY CEREMONY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED TO VOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY IS AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CORE CORE RATE.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A PUBLIC
RECORDS.
MR STONE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS WE TRY TO MODERNIZE.
THE CODES ACROSS CALIFORNIA ONE
THINGS WE DISCOVERED IN THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
IS THAT MOST DOCUMENT AND
STUDENTS REQUIRE SOMEONE TO PAY
A FEE FOR THE AGENCY.
TO DUPLICATE THE MATERIALS WHEN
IN FACTMOST OF US CARRY A
SCANNER IN OUR POCKET OR PURSE
THAT IS PERFECTLY ADEQUATE FOR
THE JOB.
THIS BILL DOES CLARIFY THAT A
REQUEST -- OF DOCUMENTS CAN USE
THAT DEVICE TO MAKE COPIES AS
LONG AS THEY'RE NOT DESTROYING
WERE TODAY AT THAT ARE TAKE CARE
OF THOSE.
MATERIALS TO BE ABLE TO USE A
CELL PHONE OR OTHER PORTABLE
SCANNER TO SCAN FOR THEMSELVES
DOCUMENTS THEY REQUESTED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WERE STONE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM FOR CLUB THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS ARE IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE AND
SEVENTY TWO PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE IS AB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY MS GONZALEZ
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS ALSO EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- GOOD
AFTERNOON EIGHT TWENTY FOURTEEN
URBAN INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND THAT
MANY VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING WERE SUBJECT TO A
VARIETY OF PHYSICAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL TACTICS MEANT TO
CONTROL IN SLAVE THE VICTIMS.
INCLUDING THE USE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE DOCUMENT SERVITUDE AS
A PRACTICE OF AN EMPLOYER
WITHHOLDING AND IMMIGRANTS LEGAL
DOCUMENTS FOR PURPOSES OF
MANIPULATING THE EMPLOYEE.
WITH THE VAST MAJORITY OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS BEING
IMMIGRANTS IT'S VITAL THAT WE
PROTECT THESE WORKERS BY
PREVENTING UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THEIR EMIGRATE XIN STATUS.
AB FIVE EIGHTY NINE HELPS
PROTECT WORKERS I CAN SEE MORE
OF A MORAL PRACTICE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE BY PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK TO HOLD EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE WHO ENGAGE IN THIS
ACTIVITY.
AND DETERMINE A VIOLATION IS A
MISDEMEANOR WITH THE POTENTIAL
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS CIVIL
PENALTY AND ESTABLISHING A
WORKERS BILL RIGHT SO MUCH
EMPLOYER MUST PROVIDE A COPY TO
EVERY WORKER.
I WILL NOTE THAT THIS BILL WAS
BROUGHT TO ME IN SPONSORED BY MY
REPUBLICAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY IT
IS NOT A CRAZY WORKER BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
WEIRD FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX AC
ARE SEVENTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN
OTHERS RELATIVE TO BONE MARROW
DONATION AWARENESS MONTH.
MR BERMAN ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY HONOR TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY CURRENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SEVENTY WHICH DESIGNATES MAY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS BONE MARROW
DONATION AWARENESS MONTH.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
NATIONAL MARROW DONOR PROGRAM
NOT KNOWN AS BE THE MATCH HAS
FACILITATED BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANTS THROUGH A NATIONAL
REGISTRY OF VOLUNTEER DONORS.
UNFORTUNATELY 70% OF PATIENTS
SEEKING A DONOR DO NOT HAVE A
FULLY MATCHED DONOR IN THEIR
FAMILY.
AS A RESULT PATIENTS OFTEN RELY
ON THE SELFLESS COMMITMENT OF
STRANGERS FOR A CURE.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT I'M LIKE BLOOD DONATION
PATIENTS SEEKING A BONE MARROW
DONOR ARE MOST LIKELY TO MATCH
SOMEONE WHO SHARES THEIR ETHNIC
BACKGROUND.
THEREFORE INCREASING DIVERSITY
IN THE BONE MARROW DONATION
REGISTRY IS ESSENTIAL.
ACR SEVENTY WAS INSPIRED BY FIVE
YEAR OL NOR GRATZ LAZARUS WHO
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A RARE
GENETIC DISORDER CALLED FANCONI
ANEMIA AND IS CURRENTLY SEEKING
A MATCHING BONE MARROW DONOR.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
MORE CALIFORNIANS TO JOIN THE
REGISTRY WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
FINDING A MATCH FOR NORA AND
OTHERS IN NEED.
I'VE JOINED THE REGS I HAVE
JOINED THE REGISTRY AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO JOIN IT AS WELL --
THE REGISTRATION IS PROCESS IS
REALLY SIMPLE YOU REGISTER
ONLINE AT JOIN DOT BE THE MATCH
DOT ORG.
YOU RECEIVE A CHEEK SWAB KIT IN
THE MAIL.
AND THE KIDS SHOULD ARRIVE IN
ABOUT A WEEK.
YOU SWAP YOUR CHEEK YOU RETURN
THE KIT IN THE MAIL AND YOU'RE
DONE IT TAKES ABOUT FIVE MINUTES.
IT'S THAT EASY.
AND YOU CAN JOIN THE REGISTRY
AND YOU YOURSELF CAN BE THE CURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN ASSET THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN MR BLOW
YOUR RECOGNIZE QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR MISTER SPEAKER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WHAT WAS THAT.
WEBSITE AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ASKING -- TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA IT IS JOIN.
DOT BE THE MATCH.
DOT ORG.
MR BLOOM TIME THANK THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE FROM
EVERYONE ON THIS FLOOR IN THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND GO TO THE WHAT IF THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM.
AND MISTER BERMAN IS ASKING THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON A C. R..
SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SEVEN EIGHT
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER BERMAN
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUESTS INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO
THIS RESOLUTION [inaudible]
YEAH.
MR BERMAN I'M GOING RECOGNIZE
MISTER BERMAN FROM.
MISTER CALDERON DESK.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IT'S MY HONOR TO
WELCOME GUESTS WHO ARE HERE
TODAY. TO JOIN US IN RECOGNIZING
MAY IS BONE MARROW DONATION
AWARENESS MONTH THERE IN THE
GALLERY RIGHT OVER HERE -- IN
THE GALLERY I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST WALKING A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST NOR GRATZ LAZARUS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NORA FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND FOR INSPIRING THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS RESOLUTION
TO BRING MUCH NEEDED ATTENTION.
TO THE BONE MARROW DONATION
REGISTRY -- I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE -- THE NOR IS GOING BY
OUR FATHERS ACT.
HER MOTHER RACHEL HER YOUNGER
BROTHER ELLIS AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BE THE
MATCH THE NATIONAL MARROW DONOR
PROGRAM.
ZACKS ACTUALLY A FRIEND OF MINE
FROM A YOUNG A YOUNG LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM IN LA A LONG LONG TIME
AGO -- AND THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH
FOR YOUR EFFORTS IN RAISING
AWARENESS IN ENCOURAGING MORE
PEOPLE TO JOIN THE REGISTRY.
OUR GOAL IS TO FIND A MATCHING
DONOR FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING NOR AND OTHERS IN NEED
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE SPECIAL GUESTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE
IN FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN OR FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY NINE AB SEVEN FORTY SIX
BY DOCTOR WOULD COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER WOULDN'T ACT
RELATING TO YOUR MANY FACTORS.
THAT'S WHAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW
WHEN INDUSTRY GROWS QUICKLY WE
NEED TO CLARIFY AN UPDATE
EXISTING LAWS.
AND THERE ARE A FEW INDUSTRIES
THERE ARE FEW INDUSTRIES IN OUR
STATE THAT ARE GROWING FASTER
THAN THE CRAFT BEER INDUSTRY.
MEMBERS THIS BILL SIMPLY
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW BY
ENSURING THE HOLDER OF A BEER
MANUFACTURES LICENSE ENJOYS THE
SAME FLEXIBILITY WITH REGARD. TO
THE SHERMAN FOOD DRUG AND
COSMETIC LAWS WINEGROWERS IN
BLENDERS IS A NON CONTROVERSIAL
BILL THERE'S BEEN ON CONSENT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES.
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN FIVE
MISTER KANSEN CHU CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
ACCOLADES RAFFLE ATHLETES.
MR CHIU YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO DATE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH UPDATES THE ATHLETES
AGENTS ACT. TO RECENTLY AND
ACTED RULES OF THE AND DOUBLE
AND SEE DOUBLE A THE PURPOSE OF
EIGHT FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN IS TO
ALLOW RECENT NC DOUBLE AID RULES
CHANGES. TO COME TO IF FACT IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT POLISH TRAIN --
A POP AND PUNISHING OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES.
THE BILL CAME STRONG DO YOU A
REQUEST OVER STATE UNIVERSITIES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THINGS CHIU SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SERIES YOU KNOW ZERO
OF THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE IS AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE CORPORATE MISS WICKS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AS WE ALL KNOW AND FEEL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY SINGLE DAY WE
ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WE HAVE TO BUILD MORE HOMES
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS BUT WE ALSO
TO FIND OTHER TYPES OF CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS.
MY BILL AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE
PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE PAYMENT
FOR PROPERTIES LEAST TO AN
OPERATED BY A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WHEN A PROPERTY
OWNER CONVERTS THEIR EXISTING
BUILDING.
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IS
IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM -- IN MY TO
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CITY OF OAKLAND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY CAME AS WICKS SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO IS
AB. FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE
AN ACCOLADE STATE GOVERNMENT.
MR OF AN AUNTIE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M SURE
EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER IS
AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES FACING
THE STATE'S PHYS CAL SYSTEM.
LAST YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR
CONDUCTED AN AUDIT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HIS CAL IN WHICH
THEY SURVEYED SEVENTEEN STATE
AGENCIES THAT WERE DEPLOYING
OFFICE CAL THEY EXPRESSED
CONCERNS.
OVER THE ABILITY OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM TO BE USED IN.
PRODUCING THE STATE'S
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FISCAL
REPORT AND RAISE THE CONCERN
THAT THIS COULD EVENTUALLY
AFFECT THE STATE'S CREDIT RATING.
JUST SEVERAL WEEKS AGO STATE
COMPTROLLER BETTY SENT A LETTER
ADDRESSED TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
WHICH SHE EXPRESSED GRAVE
CONCERNS THAT HEARD APART WOULD
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PRODUCE THE
CFR ON TIME THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IMPLEMENTS THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HIS CAL TO INCLUDE
CERTAIN METRICS IN THEIR ANNUAL
REPORT. TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE FISCAL
SYSTEM THIS WILL ENABLE US TO DO
OUR JOB IN EXERCISING OVERSIGHT
OVER THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
SYSTEM.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVERLOADING
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THE RESEARCHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE TO PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY THREE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR A. C. A. A LEVIN.
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME THE CONSTITUTIONAL MEMINTA
LEVIN BY SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO THE
OFFICE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S.
MR OF REALTY OF MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS AN ALMOST
EIGHTY YEAR HISTORY.
IN ASSISTING THE LEGISLATURE AND
MAKING GOOD FISCAL DECISIONS
ABOUT THE FINANCES OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY THE
ONLY -- IN ADDITION TO ASSISTING
US ON THE BUDGET ALSO CONDUCTED
A FISCAL ANALYSIS OF EVERY
SINGLE BILL THAT WENT THROUGH
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER IN NINETEEN NINETY THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA PASSED PROP
ONE FORTY WHICH IN ADDITION TO
IMPOSING TERM LIMITS ON THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO IMPOSE VERY
STRICT SPENDING LIMITS.
ON UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
PROP ONE FORTY WAS THE LA --
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF PROP ONE
FORTY THE ALLEY -- STAFF WOULD
CUT BY OVER 60% AND IT HAS NEVER
BEEN RESTORED IN FACT RIGHT NOW
THE LA -- HAS THE SAME NUMBER OF
ANALYST AS IT DID IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX AND IN THE INTERVENING
STATE GOVERNMENT HAS GROWN BY
OVER FIFTY TIMES.
NO NORMALLY I AM A PROPONENT OF
SMALLER GOVERNMENT BUT I MAKE AN
EXCEPTION WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR BEING THE FISCAL
WATCHDOG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO DO THEIR JOB THIS
BILL WILL TAKE THE ONLY -- OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH THE PROP ONE
FORTY CAPS AND ALLOW THEM TO DO
THE JOB THAT THEY SHOULD BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE COLLEGE THIS IS
A BASIC GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A CA.
ELEVEN THANK YOU MISTER OVER
NOTING SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
ON THE ACA.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE AJ ARE.
EIGHT CORPORATION.
SOME JOINT RESOLUTION EIGHT BY
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE. TO INVASIVE SPECIES.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AJ
ARE I REQUEST THAT CONGRESS SAID
CALIFORNIA.
REVISIONS OF THE NUTRIA CONTROL
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND THREE IN
AUTHORIZED A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATIONS TO CALIFORNIA FOR
RATIFICATION OF NUTRIA.
AJ ARE EIGHT SEEKS TO BRING THE
SAME PROGRAM THAT SUCCESSFULLY
THE CHESAPEAKE BAY BELL
[inaudible] TO CALIFORNIA.
NEW TREE ARE LARGE AQUATIC ROAD
INSTEAD OF RECENTLY ESTABLISHED
INVASIVE PRESENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- TEAR NUTRIA
REPRODUCE RAPIDLY IN A VERY
DESTRUCTIVE EATING BEARING
HABITS.
THEIR THREAT TO THE STATE'S
DELEGATES WETLANDS LEVEES AND
CRITICAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND I ANSWERED THE FIRST BALLOT
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU THAT QUIRK SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE H. A
R. DR COURSE ASSN VIRTUAL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE.
EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED
THIS IS AJ ARE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TIE BUT I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
PASS RETAIN A FILE OUT OF EIGHTY
SIX FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN IS AB NINE TWELVE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
QUICK READ OF THE MENACE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWELVE OF THE
MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
MISTER MURATSUCHI ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I'M PRESENTING AB
NINE TWELVE FOR AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE.
I ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE AT
THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT
OF PRINT.
IN BACK ON FILE FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY EIGHT IS AB.
SIX EIGHTEEN CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER MARK STONE
INOCULATED TAXATION.
MR STONE YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS CITY OF SCOTTS VALLEY IS
A LOW WELL CITY AND IS BENT VERY
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BUT AS
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THEIR
BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR THEY'RE
REALIZING THAT THERE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL. FOR SOME SIGNIFICANT
SHORTFALLS SO THE ASSET I CARRY
THIS BILL THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
INCREASE. TO GO TO THE VOTERS TO
INCREASE THEIR SALES TAX RATE
ABOVE THE CURRENT STATUTORY
MAXIMUM WE SEEN THESE BILLS
BEFORE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WERE STONE SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WELL OVERALL.
VERY SAD ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB SIX SEVENTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE COMMON
INTERESTS OF ELEMENTS.
MISS FRIEDMAN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TODAY TO PRESENT A. B. --
SIX SEVENTY I AM A BIG FAN OF
EIGHTY USE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AS ONE OF OUR SOLUTIONS TO
OUR STATE'S HOUSING PROBLEMS --
BUT WHEN THE ORIGINAL LAW WAS
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO THERE WAS
I BELIEVE A LOOPHOLE A BIT OF AN
OVERSIGHT.
IN THE ORIGINAL LAW THAT I BET
THAT A LOT OF YOU DIDN'T REALIZE --
HAPPEN WHICH WAS THAT COMMUNITY
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS ARE
BASICALLY -- H. O. WAYS IN MANY
CASES HAVE THE ABILITY TO JUST
FLAT OUT -- DISALLOW EIGHTY USE
IN THEIR JURISDICTION WE DON'T
ALLOW THAT FOR CITIES BUT
SOMEHOW WE ALLOWED FOR EACH --
WAYS THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY SAY
THAT H. ALWAYS COULD HAVE
REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS SUCH AS
DESIGN -- OVERSIGHT FOR EASY USE
BUT NOT DE FACTO BAN THEM THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED A STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES AND I WOULD REQUEST REALLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS FREEMAN
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN ROLE.
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
THOSE ARE ALL TIED BUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
NINETY FILE ITEM NINETY ONE A.
B. THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR CORKERY.
SUMI BILL THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER DALY AN
ACCOLADE THE JUVENILES MR DAILY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL ELIMINATES THE
FEE FOR PETITIONING THE COURT TO
SEAL A JUVENILE RECORD.
CURRENT LAW PASSED FOUR YEARS
AGO WAVES THE FEE FOR
INDIVIDUALS UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX THIS BILL IS A
LOGICAL STEP FOR BECAUSE IT
WAVES THE FEE FOR ANY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO SEAL THEIR JUVENILE
RECORD.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY CITY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT
I SIXTY NINE KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NINETY TWO THROUGH
NINETY FIVE HOUSE RETAIN WERE
FILE ITEM NINETY SIX A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACCOLADE A LAND USE THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ASSIST THE
COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATE PROCESS TO
PROVIDE CLARITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND RESIDENTS IN DEVELOPERS
ABOUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT AN
UPDATED COMMUNITY PLAN SHOULD TO
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT BE A
CHALLENGE IN COURT NO I MANY OF
OUR LARGER LOCALITIES SUCH AS
LOS ANGELES.
WHEN A COMMUNITY WANTS TO UPDATE
THEIR GENERAL PLAN THEY DO IT
NEIGHBORHOOD BY NEIGHBORHOOD OR
COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY?
AND IN SOME CASES THOSE PLANS
GET CHALLENGE BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
IN THE LAW WHAT HAPPENS TO
DEVELOPMENTS IN OTHER PROJECTS
THAT ARE CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
A SECRET CHALLENGE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL SAYS IS THAT
IF YOU'RE UNDERLYING COMMUNITY
PLAN IS CHALLENGED IN COURT AND
LET'S SAY A JUDGE ISSUES A STAY
ON THE PLAN.
IF A PROJECT HAD BEEN DEEMED
COMPLETE OR APPROVED BEFORE THE
JUDGE PUT THAT STAY IT CAN STILL
PROCEED WHICH MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE OF PEOPLE OF SEVERAL ISN'T
THAT WHAT HAPPENS.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT IT'S NOT
ALWAYS WHAT HAPPENS BECAUSE
CITIES ARE AFRAID TO APPROVE OR
LET THOSE PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE LAW AS FAR AS WE CAN SEE.
THAT SAYS THEY HAVE TO BE
STOPPED BUT THIS IS HAPPEN IN
LOS ANGELES AND OTHER PLACES SO
THIS GIVES CLARITY TO THE LAW
AND SIMPLY SAYS THAT IF YOU'VE.
DONE ALL OF YOUR WORK AND YOU
BUT YOU'VE FOR FILLED WHAT WAS
IT EXISTING COMMUTE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF WHAT WAS IN
EXISTING AND APPROVE COMMUNITY
PLAN AND DONE YOUR DUE DILIGENCE
AND OTTEN YOUR APPROVALS.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROCEED
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS -- TO
THAT COMMUNITY PLAN LATER ON
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OVERALL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IN A DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIX NINE
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
AHEAD IN THE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY AC ARE.
EIGHTY THREE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS
AWARENESS MONTH.
MISTER RAMOS ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR EIGHTY THREE
WHICH WOULD DESIGNATE THE MONTH
OF MAY AS CALIFORNIA'S MISSING
MURDER INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND
GIRLS AWARENESS MONTH.
WITH CALIFORNIA BEING HOME TO
MORE PEOPLE OF NATIVE AMERICAN
ALASKA NATIVE HERITAGE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE BRING
AWARENESS TO THIS EPIDEMIC.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AMERICAN INDIAN WOMEN
FACE MURDER RATES THAT ARE MORE
THAN TEN TIMES THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA S
NUMBER SIX ON THE TOP TEN OF THE
STATE WITH THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
THESE TYPES OF CASES.
AND SAN FRANCISCO AS ONE OF THE
TOP TEN CITIES WITH THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
IS ALARMING.
WITH MAY FIFTH AS THE NATIONAL
DAY OF AWARENESS FOR MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
PLEASE BRING PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RAISING AWARENESS ON THE HIGH
RATES OF HOMICIDE OF AMERICAN
INDIAN AND ALASKA NATIVE WOMEN
AS WELL AS OTHER FORMS OF
VIOLENCE INCLUDING.
SEX TRAFFICKING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE WAS ROSS MISTER FRAZIER HERE
RECOGNIZE.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND FOR
BRING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD.
YOU'VE HEARD THE STATISTICS
THESE WOMEN AND GIRLS FACE AN
EPIDEMIC EPIDEMIC OF VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE FAMILIES FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN FAILED IN
THEIR DARKEST HOUR.
WE ALL SHARE THE SAME GOAL KEEP.
KEEPING ONE ANOTHER SAFE.
NO MOTHER SHOULD BE TAKEN FROM
HER FAMILY NO PARENT SHOULD LOSE
THEIR CHILD.
IT'S PAST TIME TO FURTHER THAT
GOAL AND HELP MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
FOR OUR NATIVE COMMUNITIES.
ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND FOR
CALLING ATTENTION TO THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE.
AND I STRONGLY URGE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION.
MISTER KALRA YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A RISE TO POWER CO AUTHOR ACR
EIGHTY THREE BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
I HAVE A VIBRANT ACTIVE
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY MY DISTRICT --
APPRECIATE THESE EFFORTS OF THE
VOICES OF THE COUNTLESS MISSING
INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
WHILE MOST OF THE DATA THAT
EXISTS ON MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WHEN REFER TO OUR
STOLEN SISTERS ON RESERVATIONS.
OVER 70% OF NATIVE PEOPLE THAT
IN URBAN CITIES.
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS SPACE
MURDER RATES UP TO TEN TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND AS THE
STATE WITH THE LARGEST SELF
IDENTIFYING INDIGENOUS
POPULATION.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO SHED
LIGHT ON THIS ADDRESS TODAY.
THIS IS A CRITICAL RESOLUTION ON
THE ADVOCACY WORK OF THE
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY TO RAISE
AWARENESS IS A TRUE TESTAMENT TO
THEIR STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE
PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN SUPPORT OF A C. R..
EIGHTY THREE DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF AID
ACR.
EIGHTY THREE AND I WANNA THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THE
SUBJECT FORWARD.
YOU KNOW WHEN I HEARD ABOUT IT I
WAS APPALLED BECAUSE CLEARLY
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS CAR OR A
BLEMISH ON OUR SOCIETY THAT WE
HAVE SO MANY WOMEN WHO ARE
MISSING WILL BEEN ABUSED.
AND YET WE ARE SO ON AWARE OF
WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT THE
SITUATION IS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR MAKING
ME AWARE OF THE REAL CRISIS THAT
WE FACE.
AND IT REMINDS ME SO OFTEN OF
HOW WE DISREGARD POPULATIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE DON'T SEE AS
BEING VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE WERE PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY
THAT WE JUST DON'T SEE THEIR
INVISIBLE AND EVEN THE
ATROCITIES THAT THEY SUFFER OR
SOMETIMES NOT FELT BY THE REST
OF US AND THEY SHOULD BE.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK OF THIS I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT WE DO
NORMALLY WHEN WE SEE OTHER
CHILDREN AND OTHER WOMEN WHO ARE
MISSING.
AND THE KIND OF URGENCY IN THE
KIND OF OUTCRY THAT WE
EXPERIENCE IF THIS WERE
HAPPENING TO THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN OF WAS HAPPENING TO
WHITE WOMEN IN THIS SOCIETY.
I'M REMINDED SO JOHN A TRUTH
WHEN SHE WAS NOT BEING TREATED
LIKE A QUOTE A WOMAN SHE ASKED
THE QUESTION BUT A NOT A WOMAN.
AND I THINK WE ASK THE SAME
QUESTION OF OUR SISTERS WHO ARE
WHO ARE PART OF THIS INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY ARE THESE WOMEN ARE
THESE OF INDIVIDUALS A PART OF
WHO WE ARE.
ARE THERE THE MOTHERS AND
DAUGHTERS OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
THEY THE ONES WHO ROCK THE
CRADLE AND THAT'S RULE THE WORLD.
WE HAVE BASICALLY FAILED AS A
SOCIETY IN IGNORING THE WOMEN
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY I
WANT THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
MAKING US KEENLY AWARE.
THAT WE HAVE A CRISIS AND SHOULD
NOT JUST BE A RESOLUTION GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE A MOVEMENT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE RESOURCES
WE HAVE.
AND HOW WE PROTECT EVERY WOMAN
IN CALIFORNIA AND EVERY WOMAN IN
THIS NATION AND THAT ALL OF US
HAVE VALUE AND WE SHOULD ALL
FEEL THE SAME LOS WE HAVE THIS
NUMBER OF WOMEN.
WHO NO LONGER ARE PART OF US AND
HAVE SOMEHOW TO THE BEEN SHIFTED
AWAY TO SOMEWHERE ELSE?
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
MAKING ME CONSCIOUS AND AWARE OF
IT I HOPE THIS HOUSE ONCE AGAIN.
NOT ONLY SUPPORTS THIS
RESOLUTION BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
WILL BUT THAT WE PUT OUR
RESOURCES IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS NEVER HAPPENS ANYMORE
AND AGAIN THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DOUG WEBER THIS
CARILLO.
YOUR RECORD.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION TO THE FLOOR.
AS A FORMER JOURNALIST I HAVE
COVERED THE RISE OF INDIGENOUS
WOMEN AND NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
BEING MURDERED.
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
AS A WOMAN WHO IDENTIFIES AS
BEING AN INDIGENOUS WOMAN THIS
IS VERY DEEP AND VERY PERSONAL
BECAUSE OUR VOICES AND THE
VOICES OF WOMEN.
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND ACROSS
THE WORLD WHO IDENTIFIES NATIVE
AMERICAN ARE INDIGENOUS HAVE
OFTEN BEEN.
IGNORED SO THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
FOR FROM THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MYSTERY I'LL SAY NO
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MISTER RAMOS YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU TO ALL THE CO
AUTHORS -- THAT ACCOMPANY SPOKE
UP TO THIS ISSUE THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT HOPEFULLY WE COULD
BRING MORE AWARENESS MORE
ADVOCACY AND REALLY -- AS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER'S COMMENTS
MOVE FORWARD IN A MOVEMENT TO
START TO BRING THESE THINGS
FORWARD AND BRING IN THE
RESOURCES OUT TO THOSE THAT ARE
OUT THERE IN THESE DIRE NEEDS
THAT ARE THERE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR RAHMAN WHO WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE YES
YES MISTER SPEAKER.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C. R..
EIGHTY THREE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SEVENTY THREE
CO AUTHORS ADDED IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE A FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
ONE H. R..
THIRTY BY MS SMITH CORPORATION.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH RELATIVE
TODAY OF A TEACHER.
SMITH YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND HR THIRTY
RECOGNIZING THE DAY OF THE
TEACHER.
ALL OF US HAVE HAD AT LEAST ONE
AMAZING EXPERIENCE WITH A
TEACHER IN OUR LIVES.
WE KNOW WHAT THOSE EXPERIENCES
HAVE BEEN LIKE FOR OUR OWN
CHILDREN.
AND THE SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
THAT A TEACHER CAN MAKE.
WE RECOGNIZE AMONG OUR OWN
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES A NUMBER OF
TEACHERS WHOSE THOUGHTFUL
PRESENCE IN OUR BODY ADDS SO
MUCH TO OUR WORK.
BUT YET IN THE CURRENT CONTEXT I
THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE.
SO THIS RECOGNITION SERVES AS
THE START.
OF A WEEK IN WHICH TEACHERS
ACROSS THE STATE WILL BE
CELEBRATED WITH FLOWERS AND
LUNCHES AND DECORATED CLASSROOMS
AND THOUGHTFUL NOTES FROM
STUDENTS AND THE FAMILIES THEY
SERVE.
HOWEVER THE CURRENT CONTEXT FOR
TEACHERS REMAINS A CHALLENGING.
ONE COLLEAGUES WE STILL REMAIN
IN THE BOTTOM TEN STATES IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL FUNDING.
IT'S SOMETHING I KNOW WE NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE WE GRAPPLE WITH BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR OUR STATE
TEACHERS.
EVEN UNDER THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA MANY DISTRICTS
AND THEIR BY THEIR TEACHERS
PERSEVERE DOING MORE WITH LESS.
THEY'VE ACCEPTED THE CHALLENGE
OF TRANSITIONING TO THE COMMON
CORE STATE STANDARDS PURSUING
MODELS OF TEACHING COLLABORATION
AND DIFFERENTIATED INSTRUCTION
FOR STUDENTS WHICH GO TO THE
VERY HEART OF ELIMINATING OUR
STATE SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS.
UNDER A NEW AND MUCH MORE
RIGOROUS ASSESSMENT SYSTEM.
THEY REACH OUT TO WELCOME AND
INTEGRATE STUDENTS WITH DIVERSE
LEARNING NEEDS INTO THEIR
CLASSROOMS OFTEN OFFERING
INSTRUCTION THAT IS UNIQUE AS
EACH CHILD THEY SERVE.
AND THEY UNDERTAKE ALL OF THESE
TASKS WHILE BEING COGNIZANT OF
THEIR SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
INSPIRING THEIR STUDENTS LOVE OF
LEARNING.
AND CREATIVITY.
TEACHERS ARE EVER VIGILANT ON
THE FRONT LINES WERE SO MANY OF
OUR SOCIETAL CHALLENGES AND FIND
MORE THAN EVER THEY ARE THE
CRITICAL LINK IN CONNECTING
THEIR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. TO SERVICES TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS AND THEIR
GREATEST NEEDS.
AND THEIR SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING.
AND IT'S NOT VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF THEIR WORK WHERE WE AS A BODY
CANNOT LET THEM FALL SHORT.
WE MUST MOVE FORWARD IN SEEKING
THE MEANS TO ENSURE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND CHILD CENTERED
SUPPORT ARE AVAILABLE IN EVERY
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND ALLOW TEACHERS TO CONTINUE
TO MAKE THOSE CRITICAL LINKS FOR
THEIR STUDENTS.
WE MUST RECOGNIZE IT AS WE FACE
A LOOMING TEACHER SHORTAGE WE
MUST DO MORE THAN EVER. TO
ELEVATE THE PROFESSION. TO HONOR
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
TEACHERS AND CONTINUE IN OUR
QUEST TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE SO THAT
TEACHERS NO WE HAVE THEIR BACKS.
LET US RAISE OUR COLLECTIVE
VOICES TODAY IN RECOGNITION FOR
THE COMPASSION HEART.
AND FEARS HARD WORK OUR TEACHERS
BRING TO THEIR WORK.
AND START THIS WEEK OF
CELEBRATION FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY MAKE TO OUR
STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE HOUSE RESOLUTION.
MISS SMITH WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE YES
MISTER SPEAKER.
PERSONAL BE ABLE FOR CALL OFFICE
CLERK WILL BE THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON H. R. THIRTY THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL. ZERO THERE ARE
SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SING HEARING NONE CLERK READ THE
SECOND ACHES ENCOUNTER.
SOME BILL LEVIN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER ALMOST ANOTHER
CYNICAL INTO VESSELS.
WELL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT.
ALL MEMBERS WERE RESERVE OF THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SOME PEOPLE THREE FIFTY THREE I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SUM A BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO SO LEGAL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO AND ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY I SEVENTY FIVE
NO.
ZERO MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MR BIGELOW I BELIEVE YOU HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THE BODY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK FOR YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I HAVE A RIVETING REMINDER FOR
EVERYONE.
THIS WEDNESDAY MAY EIGHTH IS THE
FORTY FIFTH ANNUAL CAPITAL FROG
JUMP PLEASE DON'T MISS OUT
MEMBERS.
PLEASE SIGN UP CONTACT MY OFFICE
AND LET'S ALL HAVE FUN ON
WEDNESDAY MAY THE EIGHTH JUMPING
ARE FROGS.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY MAY SEVENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY EIGHTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
NINTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT A GERMAN TO
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SO WE MAY PROCEED
[inaudible]
DR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMANY MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO ACID WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF VETERAN DR MARION
WOODS OF RANCHO MURIETA.
DR WOODS WAS A SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC PIONEER THAT LET
SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
FROM DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO THE
CALIFORNIADEPARTMENT OF
EMPLOYMENT WELL HE WAS
SUPERINTENDENT OF MINORITY
EMPLOYMENT.
MARY MADE SURE EVERYONE FELT
WELCOME.
DOCTOR WOULD USE HIS KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE TO BECOME A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE WHOSE
MISSION IT WAS TO ENHANCE
EDUCATION AND JOB DEVELOPMENT
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
DOCTOR WOULD WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN GEORGIA.
AND WENT TO MOREHOUSE COLLEGE
WITH DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR IN ATLANTA.
OVER IS EIGHTY SEVEN YEARS OF
LIFE MARION RECEIVED COUNTLESS
AWARDS FOR STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
DESPITE ALL OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND MULTIPLE
CAREERS DOCTOR WOULD REMAIN
HUMBLE AND GROUNDED.
I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT MOST OF
YOU TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GOOGLE HIS NAME.
AND TO SEE ALL THE WONDERFUL
STORIES HE HAD ABOUT GROWING UP
IN ATLANTA.
AND HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH DR
KING AND DOCTOR KING'S FATHER.
AND ALL OF THE THINGS HE LEARNED
IN THE PROCESS OF MOVING THROUGH
ATLANTA AT THE PARTICULAR TIME
IN GOING TO MORE HOUSE.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT HE
ATTENDED DR MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
FUNERAL IT WAS AT THAT FEEL THAT
HE BECAME INSPIRED TO COME BACK
TO SACRAMENTO.
AND BASICALLY BEGIN THE URBAN
LEAGUE IN SEVERAL OF THE SOCIAL
ORGANIZATIONS HE SAID HE NEVER
ENVISIONED HIMSELF AS A LEADER
IN THAT SENSE BUT ONCE HE SAW
THE KING'S LIFE HAD BEEN TAKEN
AS HE STRUGGLED TO CREATE.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS IT
MOTIVATED HIM TO DO LIKEWISE AND
SUCH SO HE RETURNED TO
SACRAMENTO AND BECAME A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF CAT OF
SACRAMENTO'S LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA'S LIFE.
IN CREATING EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS IN EVERY POSITION THE
HAT.
HE WAS WELL RESPECTED BY THE
MEMBERS HERE AT THE CAPITOL IN
THOSE IN THE VARIOUS AGENCIES
SURROUNDING THE CAPITAL BECAUSE
OF HIS DILIGENTLY HARDWORKING
ATTITUDE.
BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT HIS HUMBLE
SPIRIT THAT MADE THAT OFTEN MADE
PEOPLE WONDER WHO HE WAS WHEN HE
WALKS IN A ROOM ONLY TO DISCOVER
THAT HE WAS DIRECTOR OF THE
PROGRAM A DIRECTOR OF THE AGENCY.
IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF HIM WHO
LIVED A MAN WHO LIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WONDERFUL YEARS BORN IN
THE SOUTH AT A TIME WHEN
DISCRIMINATION OBVIOUSLY WAS
RAMPANT.
BEING A VICTIM OF SEGREGATION
AND JIM CROW LAWS AND YET RISING
ABOVE A TO HAVE ALWAYS THE
SPIRIT OF GIVING AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS TO
EVERYONE HE MET.
HE WILL BE TRULY MISSED BY THIS
CAPITAL BY THE PEOPLE SACRAMENTO.
HE WAS A HUSBAND A FATHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS A GRANDFATHER
GREAT GRANDFATHER AND FRIEND I
ASSN WE ARE JOINED IN MEMORY OF
MARION WOODS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MISTER KALRA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND SALEM AN HONOR FOR ME TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK
IN MEMORY AND IN HONOR.
OF LI TONG.
LEAVE TRONG WAS BORN ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST NINETEEN FORTY
SIX AND WAY VIETNAM.
FAMOUSLY KNOWN AS THE VIETNAMESE
JAMES BOND.
LI TONG WAS A SOUTH VIETNAMESE
FIGHTER PILOT AND FREEDOM
FIGHTER.
WHO ACTIVELY STOOD UP THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT WHEN THEY
TOOK OVER VIETNAM?
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTEEN HE SERVED IN
THE SOUTH REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM
AIR FORCE WAS ALSO ASSIGNED. TO
SOUTH VIETNAM'S BLACK EAGLE
FIGHTER SQUADRON. ONE OF HIS
MOST FAMOUS ANTI COMMUNIST
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT DUBBED HIM THE
VIETNAMESE JAMES BOND OCCURRED
ON SEPTEMBER FOURTH.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WHEN HE
HIJACKED AN AIR VIETNAM FLIGHT
CARRYING A HUNDRED TO FIVE
PASSENGERS.
FROM BANGKOK TO SAIGON.
SO THAT HE CAN DROP OUT
THOUSANDS OF ANTI COMMUNIST.
LEAFLETS.
HE WAS KNOWN FOR FLYING OVER
OTHER COUNTRIES.
OF AS WELL SOUTH KOREA CUBA TO
SPREAD ANTI COMMUNIST LEAFLETS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR LI TONG
WAS GRANTED ASYLUM TO THE UNITED
STATES AND HE RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM THEN PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN FOR HIS STRUGGLE TO
ATTAIN FREEDOM FROM CAPTIVITY IN
VIETNAM.
LI TONG MADE HIS IMPACT IN SAN
JOSE WHEN HE CONDUCTED A HUNGER
STRIKE.
FROM FEBRUARY THROUGH MARCH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AT SAN JOSE CITY
HALL.
SAN JOSE BEING HOME TO A LARGE
VICTORIES POPULATION OF ANYONE
CITY OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
WAS CONSIDERING THE NAMING OF A
NEW BUSINESS DISTRICT HAS BEEN --
BUSINESS DISTRICT INSTEAD OF
LITTLE SAIGON.
WHICH WAS CHOSEN AND SUPPORTED
BY THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY.
HIS HUNGER STRIKE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING KEEP THE
NAME LITTLE SAIGON WHICH TO THIS
DAY.
IS ONE OF THE MOST VIBRANT
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE IN THE SOUTH
BAY AREA.
LI TONG WAS A LONG TIME RESIDENT
OF SAN JOSE BUT RETURNED TO SAN
DIEGO RE PASSED AWAY.
ON APRIL FIFTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I HAD THE
GREAT PLEASURE OF KNOWING.
MISTER TONG -- YET A LARGE A
LIFE PERSONALITY AND SACRIFICED
SO MUCH TO CONTINUE. TO FIGHT
FOR THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM AND HE
WILL CERTAINLY BE MESSED.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOINING IN MEMORY OF LEE TOM.
A MISTER DEEP YOU'RE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS ARE GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF A
COLLEAGUES I ALSO ALL RIGHTS TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM -- SAN
JOSE IN HONORING THIS MAN -- AS
A YOUNG STAFFER OF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY BACK
IN.
THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OF WORKING ON HIS
CASE WHEN HE WAS IMPRISONED IN
THAILAND -- THROUGH A LOT OF
HARD WORK AND A LOT OF
BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT FROM OUR CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION A WE'VE MANAGED TO
SECURE HIS RELEASED FROM THE
TYPE.
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD
HAVE BEEN -- SOMETHING VERY VERY
WORSE IN VIETNAM.
AND WHAT WHEN IT COMES TO HIM A
LOT OF WORDS WILL COME TO MIND --
JERRY.
COURAGEOUS.
OF VERY BOLD AND COLORFUL.
I CERTAINLY WOULD NOT HAVE HAD
THE COURAGE.
TO TAKE A PLANE FLY OVER CUBA.
OF FLY OVER VIETNAM AND DROP
ANTI COMMUNIST LEAFLET.
BUT THIS MAN DID.
AND NO FOR THAT.
THERE'S A CAR AND I OR OR OR HE
STANDING HERE TODAY -- THROUGH --
HONOR -- PART OF HIS -- HIS LIFE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTY BEEN MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU TWO ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET GERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALSO ON
THE RISE TWO HUNDRED IN JORDAN
IN MEMORY OF A A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE -- LEAD HOME -- HERE ROLE --
ARE YOU FIRST MET HIM IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND HE MOVED TO
SAN JOSE DOT OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN SOUTH SAY
HOW THE OF A BIG BIG -- WELL
COME WELCOMING PARTY FOR HIM.
AND I GOT TO KNOW HIM VERY WELL
DURING HIS OWN TWENTY SOME DAYS
ON A HUNGER STRIKE.
IN FRONT OF THE CITY HALL I WITH
THIS HOUSE THIS CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER.
AND I WAS ONE OF THE DISSENTING
VOTE -- TO TO NAME OF OF ENEMIES
COMMUNITIES ANYTHING OTHER DOWN
LITTLE SAIGON.
SO -- DOING HIS HER -- HUNGERS A
STRIKE WE VISIT HIM EVERY NIGHT
AND TRYING TO TALK HIM ALL OF
THE AND TRYING TO STRIKE A DEAL
WITH THE THOSE SOME OTHER
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND AND AND IS A
CITY OF SAN JOSE.
BOTH OF FINALLY WOULD HAVE -- TO
ASK FOR HIM TO THE HOSPITAL AND
AND IF YOU.
I'M GLAD THAT HE RECOVER FROM
THAT -- DEAL HE'D PROBABLY
LAWSUIT THE MOVE A GOOD EIGHTY
NINETY POUNDS YOU'RE DOING THAT --
A HUNGER STRIKE -- SO -- Và AND
UNDERSTAND LATER ON HE MOVED TO
SAN DIEGO AND OURS WAS ABOUT IT
A CAB.
IN TOUCH WITH HIM ON ON THE TAX
MATH.
MESSAGES AND THE EMAIL VERY VERY
SAD TO HEAR THE BAD NEWS AND
RESTING PEACEFULLY TALL.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU.
MR BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO A GERMAN IN THE MEMORY OF
DAYS A BISHOP WHO PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
IN AUBURN CALIFORNIA.
DAVE SPENT HIS ENTIRE FORTY YEAR
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AS A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL FORSTER
AND PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FORESTS.
HIS PATHWAY TO FORCE RE BEGAN
EARLY STUDYING FORESTRY AT THE
UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF FORESTRY
AND RENEWABLE NATURAL RESOURCES
AT UC DAVIS.
FROM HIS TIME AS A FORESTRY
MANAGER FOR THE SOUTHERN PACIFIC
LAND COMPANIES TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRE MOUNT
SHASTA DISTRICT. TWO IS TENURE
AS EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS LICENSING PROGRAM.
DAVE WAS AN INFLUENCE
INFLUENTIAL FIXTURE IN
CALIFORNIA'S FORESTRY INDUSTRY.
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS AS
CAL FORCE PRESIDENT AND C. E. O.
THEY WORKED DILIGENTLY TO
PROMOTE THE WORK OF CALIFORNIA'S
FORESTRY INDUSTRY AS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
BUT ALSO AS A RESPONSIBLE
STEWARD OF OUR FOREST LANDS.
HIS COMMITMENT TO THE FORESTRY
INDUSTRY COMPEL THEM TO
VOLUNTEER HIS TIME.
AS PRESIDENT OR CEO OF FOUR
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY RELATED
ORGANIZATIONS IN ADDITION TO
BEING A BOARD MEMBER OF THREE
OTHER [inaudible] THREE OTHERS.
DAVIS LOVE KNOWLEDGE AND
PROTECTION OF ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCES WILL GREATLY BE MESSED
AND I WILL MISS MY CLOSE FRIEND.
PLEASE KEEP DAVID HIS FAMILY HIS
WIFE JILL AND THEIR FOUR
CHILDREN IN YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
NAME IS BELA MISTER GALLEY OR
ALSO RECOGNIZE ON THIS
ADJOURNMENTS.
THEY MEASURES BIGGER MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE TO A JOURNEY IN THE
MEMORY OF DAVID MITCHELL FOR
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
THEY'D ENJOYED A FORESTRY CAREER
WHICH SPANNED MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS IN WHICH HE WORK IN EVERY.
AREA WITHIN THE FORESTRY
INDUSTRY.
THEY BECAME PRESIDENT CEO OF
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHERE HE
SPENT MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE FORCE
INDUSTRY AND WORK HARD TO WORK
FORCED INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE.
MET HIM WHEN YOU DID THE FOR SHE
TOURS UP IN MY DISTRICT A FEW
YEARS BACK WHEN HE WAS -- IS
STILL WORKING IN THE IN THE AS A
CEO.
PLEASE KEEP DAVID HIS WIFE JILL
AND THEIR FOUR CHILDREN.
AND HIS EXTENDED FAMILY AND
FRIENDS IN YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THEY WISH DALY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF RUBEN RUDA AND IF
YOU'VE EVER HAD THE PLEASURE OF
ENJOYING -- NEIL AT ONE OF
HOLLYWOOD'S OLDEST RESTAURANTS
THE MOVE SO AND FRANK GROW.
THEN YOU WOULD KNOW RUBEN.
HE WOULD KNOWN BY FACE WITH HIS
DEEP RED JACKET AND MATCHING RED
TIE YOU.
KNOW BY SIGNATURE MARTINIS
DUBBED AS THE BEST MARTINIS IN
HOLLYWOOD AND QUITE POSSIBLY THE
BEST IN THE WORLD.
OR YOU WOULD KNOWN AS A
BARTENDER WITH AN OPEN HEART AND
OPEN AIRS.
RUBEN RUDY WAS BORN AND DURANGO
MEXICO IN NINETEEN FIFTY AND
MOVED TO LOS ANGELES WHEN HE WAS
ONLY FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
HIS FIRST JOB WAS AT MOST ONE
FRANK AS A BUSBOY.
BUT HE QUICKLY BECAME THE
BARTENDER AND WORKED IN THAT
POSITION FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS.
THIS TIME IT MOST ON FRANK RUBIS
SERVE MANY OF HOLLYWOOD'S ELITE.
FROM THE ROLLING STONES AND BING
CROSBY TO ORSON WELLES AND
CHARLES BUKOWSKI.
READ IT WOULD OFTEN HAVE TO
DRIVE TO CAST A HOME AFTER THE
FAMOUS THE PUBLIC GOT TOO DRUNK
AND HE'D ALSO THROWN OUT MORE
CELEBRITIES THAN MOST BARTENDERS.
OF THE MOST NOTABLE I'M TOLD TO
WAS STEVE MCQUEEN.
RUDY CONSIDERED MOVES SO TO BE
IS HOME AND BROUGHT KINDNESS AND
LAUGHTER TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE
IS STATUS BAR.
HE HAD A REMARK A REMARKABLE
MEMORY AND CUSTOMERS WHO HAD NOT
STEPPED IN THE RESTAURANT FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE WERE
ASTONISHED.
THAT ROUTE IT WOULD REMEMBER
THEIR DRINK ORDERS EVEN WHEN HE
COULDN'T REMEMBER THEIR NAMES.
RITA PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
SIXTH AT TO ONLY SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD AND HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE MARIA HIS DAUGHTER
CYNTHIA SON LEONARD -- WHO
CURRENTLY WORKS AT MOUSSEAU AS A
SERVER AND BOOKKEEPER AND I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY?
THANK YOU MISTER FLEMING THANK
YOU MEMBERS ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HER IN A FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
WITH JUNE.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY NINTH AT NINE
AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED